okay thank you representative Jack um
all right I'm going to open the hearing
on House Bill 1262 relative to the
installation of a traffic signal at the
intersection of Route 111 and Irma Road
in Salem and I'm going to call upon the
Bill's Prime sponsor representative
Sweeney to open this hearing please
welcome to Public Works and highways
representative Sweeny thank you Miss uh
thank you very much uh acting chairman
uh and to the members of Public Works
and Highway committee uh my name is
representative Joe Sweeney I have the
honor of serving Salem in the State
House of Representatives Rockingham 25 I
also serve as the vice chair of the
Salem Town Council I speak before you
today to urgently urge uh you for your
support of the intersection of a
signalized intersection at the
intersection of Route 111 and irmer Road
in Salem New Hampshire I've handed out
numerous uh handouts for you all with
news articles and support from myself
and from the assistant Town manager Joe
dine of the town of Salem um to back up
our our our need for this intersection
to be signalized over the years the
intersection of Irma Road and Route 111
has been the site of numerous tragic
accidents including fatal collisions
that have deeply impacted our community
the most recent incident involving a
65-year-old motorcyc list from Newton is
a somber reminder of the ongoing danger
presented by this intersection
historical data paints a grim picture
with over 133 accidents occurring in the
last 6 years alone including the
heartbreaking loss of of Dorothy
Charlene buek uh back in November of
2016 outside the window of those
accidents now these are not mere
statistics they represent families
people's lives and the community that is
mourned uh including the surrounding
properties to the intersection and that
really just underscores the pressing
need for for action on this intersection
that we have the town of Salem has been
in talks with the state since the 2016
accident about ways to improve this
intersection and those talks are still
ongoing and really just trying to get
direction on this and and get it in
moving into the pipeline to to get a
signalized intersection there the design
currently of the intersection and I I
sent out a map to all of you uh the two
intersecting roads to Route 111 uh
connect to the intersection at a 45
degree angle uh those roads have miles
per hours of about 30 mil per hour
limits and then the route 111 at that
point is a 50 mph Zone uh you'll
typically see drivers driving 60 65 m
with the speed the flow of traffic it is
a it's a it's a heavily trafficked Road
in between Exit 3 and the towns of dairy
Salem uh Windam and uh in Hamstead uh
there's numerous large businesses along
the road that gets Trucking in the
morning in the afternoon times uh for
high traffic waves and it's it's a main
artery uh in our town and and and
frankly the the statistics that can be
provided um in the analysis of by dot
will show a picture of it not being this
intersection not being utilized as much
as other signalized intersections in
town and that's because people are
avoiding this intersection going out of
their way driving on back roads in Salem
and Derry and Hamstead to avoid the
intersection at Irma Road and Route 111
to avoid any potential tragic uh
captions I'll finish with that the cost
of inaction is just too high measured in
human lives you know one death is too
many we've had two in the last eight
years and we'll have numerous more uh if
we don't take action here and anything
that we can do to stop uh the tragedies
and the accidents and the deaths of this
intersection uh the the town of Salem is
willing to work with the state to get
this done uh and we just want to get
this done so I I I appreciate the time
obviously appreciate your considerations
and your process here when it comes to
you know a representative coming in I
need a light for my town we we hear it
all the time but I really just want to
press you on the the importance and the
need for this particular light so thank
you all okay thank you representative
Sweeny questions of representative
swinging from the committee okay
representative uh sorry uh Boyd go ahead
please thank you Mr chairman rep swing
thank you very much for your testimony
and bring forth the bill question does
the town of Salem want to retain
jurisdiction over the traffic light yes
okay follow up Mr oh yes please continue
repr thank you um in your opinion if I
and I apologize for putting you on the
spot representative are there any
emminent domain concerns that are being
raised as a consequence of The Proposal
no there there's no so to put a
signalized inter section there's no
eminent domain concerns uh for the area
there's the within the RightWay we'd
have the ability to do so there's been
another proposal floating around that do
came to a town council meeting with to
put a rotary in the intersection that
the town does not want um and that would
require eminent domain and a lengthier
process to to fix the intersection and
frankly I think inadequately so uh with
a rotary at that at that point that
juncture um so that's why we support a
lit signalized intersection that's in
the smart grid as we're updating all of
our intersections currently so that
they're timed properly with the other
intersections feeding into it and then
one question one last final up Mr
chairman thank you for the latitude I
you answered my question but I just want
to amplify the point so there have been
conversations between dot in the town of
Salem work regarding traffic caling uh
techniques that could be utilized 111
specifically either rumble strips or a
rotary rotary obviously you told me the
rotary was exploded and extinguished so
I'll push the rumble strips and ask that
question yep absolutely and and just to
further this I filed this bill I believe
it was in October or November whenever
we had to file the Bill Dot came to the
Salem Town Council in December with
their list of possible fixes to to
mitigate the causes uh they calculate
that uh rotary there which I still feel
is unacceptable uh could save up to
three lives a year whereas a lit
intersection would only save 1.3 lives a
year uh seeing as we've lost two lives
over eight years a lit intersection
would still serve the needs of what
we're looking to do here uh without
having to go into eminent domain and and
being a full process to redesign the
whole Road okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman um further questions yes
representative Abbott
please yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question was
this intersection and the traffic light
there brought up in any GA any gaset
hearing or part of the 10-year plan I I
believe it has been in the past and I've
talked to the executive Council about
this as well U but I can't speak
specifically to recent conversations on
it but I know the town of Salem has been
talking with do since 2016 on this
intersection thank you thank you any
further questions representative yes
please J thank you Mr chairman uh
representative has there been a traffic
study have just flipping through the
bill has there been a traffic study
performed there there has been and I was
I I was expecting do to be here and I'm
not sure if they are um they did a
traffic study we we actually most
recently did a traffic study that ended
uh the day before the most recent tragic
accident um at the intersection and
that's where they got the numbers from
three lives saved a year with a rotary
versus 1.2 Liv saved a year with a
signalized intersection um obviously I I
think we can look at studies every day
and find a different stud to back up
anything um I just see there's a need to
save one life a year and a lit
intersection would do that Qui than you
followup question and speed limits have
been explored in that on both 111 and
Elma Road absolutely and and we are the
town is open to working with the state
on speed limits in the road design and
and there's a number of options for them
just as a as a be as a bare minimum the
town and the people the community and
the surrounding property owners and the
residents there want to see a signalized
intersection at this intersection and
we're open to having conversations about
raise medians speed limits the whole
nine yards to to fix this intersection
and make it safer thank you thank you Mr
thank you yes please represent
fauler so I'm trying to understand that
the reason why you
prefer signalize
intersection over rotary roundabout what
we call them these days is the cost or
the time to implement it I mean if
do thinks that roundabout is a better
solution um it doesn't look from this
Photograph like there's much development
around there not really displacing
businesses is it is it the idea of using
people's of having to buy people's land
it's the problem what is what are the
major ders of this absolutely thank you
for the question there will be um more
development on the north side of Route
11s that's not seen in the the map right
now but there's already been approval
for for development there I think in
general and talking on behalf of my
constituents uh we've had roundabouts
put in other places within town uh the
the usability of the roundabouts and the
feasibility especially when we have a 50
mile per hour road with 230 and 25 M per
hour roads and that they the issue is
when people are trying to get off of the
side streets onto the main road um and I
just don't see a in reality I don't see
a roundabout aiding that that
process followup
represent um state has a lot of
experience with roundabouts in my corner
of the state Southwestern corner of the
state
so thank you any further questions
representative
Sweeny yes please thank you represent
Melvin could you tell
me how far away the next stoplight is
yep there's a there's another stop light
I believe within a mile and a half um in
both Direction directions of this
intersection um those are those are all
lit so you're going in from two lit
intersections to an unsignalized
intersection and that's where you have
people are just they just drive fast in
between the two lights thank you yes
please represent Newman yes thank you so
just to be clear on on this map here
it's the people coming from Irma Road
trying to get out on 111 going in either
direction and for Speed and everything
else of the traveling on 111 things are
happening yes yes it is and Irma Road
has a residential neighborhood right
behind the businesses so there there's
approximately 1500 residents that live
off of this or off of Irma Road in
various neighborhoods that need to
utilize this intersection to get on or
off 111 um and it's when they're pulling
uh either to the left or to the right
where they're getting into the flow of
traffic and that's where for the
accident start are caused thank you
further questions represent
bogert uh thank you Mr chairman you had
mentioned there's a development on the
uh one of the corners that have been
approved and stuff would impact fees be
used and helping to signalize that
because that's actually going to
increase the traffic trips for that
intersection I believe that's how we
would use the the especially the public
safety impact fees um and there's going
to be more development in Salem and in
Southern New Hampshire the Windam dairy
Salem line there's a lot of development
that's going on uh we had when we had
the presentation in town they put up a
photo of Route 111 and it probably
looked it looks a lot like a photo of
Route 28 40 years ago in Salem which is
now the commercial core of the town uh
we expect outside of the wetlands that
are near this property uh near this
intersection that it's all going to be
built out within the next 20 years uh we
want to get ahead of the build
out thank you any yes please represent
kazinski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um in your
research with the tragedies that have
happened here is it Road design or human
error that's caused these
accidents I I truly think it's the road
design uh part of the issue is is that
irmer road is is really at a slanted 45
degree angle to Route 111 and so if
you're at Irma Road and you're trying to
turn turn left onto Route 111 to go
towards Exit 3 uh you have to you almost
have to do a 160 uh degree turn and if
you're in the blind spot or you don't
see and you're pulling out there I think
that's when the the motorcyclist was
pulling out of Irma Road trying to go
West on 111 and that's when the car hit
them going through it um and and it's
it's you know depending on the time of
day um if the Sun is in your eyes it's
tough to tough to see that motorcycle
coming in um and that I mean
that if there was a silver bullet to
prevent traffic tragedies I know your
committee would support it 100% there's
no Silver Bullet if we could develop one
that would save all the lives and stop
all the accidents we would pursue that
um and I would support that um but this
is just a a a a response to tragedies
that have taken place um and I think we
we're open to talking about the angle of
the road and in the general design of it
as well um in order to fix it to make it
safer for for people that are commuting
and driving on the roads thank you re um
any further
questions uh represent Sweeney I wanted
to apologize for being a little tardy
here I want to welcome you to public
works thank you Mr chairman we don't
have you all that often um but I just
want you to help me understand this so
you've been having conversations with uh
and I'll get to my questions as I go
you've been having a conversation with
do about this intersection since
2016 um
do looked at this intersection probably
with participation of of your town and
they came to a
conclusion that the roundabout was the
right option for this is that correct
that yes that's what they presented to
us in December of 2023 okay December of
2023 the town the town unfortunately has
had tragedy there death so forth I
understand the passion of this the and
then when this 10-year plan came out uh
there was conversations during the gaset
hearings at one of the other
Representatives uh had
mentioned uh but am I correct that um
your signalized intersection is not
mentioned in the 10year plan as is a
project not currently no
okay that is all I have for you sir
thank you very much appreciate your time
thank thank you all for for hearing me
out and and taking this bill under
consideration and good luck with the
rest of the day thank
you uh next um I would hear from um well
my next one is Ben Frost please um New
Hampshire housing next bill you're on
the next bill okay okay is there anyone
is anyone here for do on this one yes
yes do okay
1262 yes okay I apologize please bill
anenberg from uh Department of
Transportation good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh my name is
Bill oldenberg I'm the director of
project development um for the
Department of Transportation um
and I checked off opposed um on this
bill um we're not opposed to the project
we're opposed to the process so um there
is a project in the 10-year plan uh for
this intersection it's currently under
under design um and by predetermining
that a signal um is to be installed sort
of predetermines and circumvents the
whole uh process from from a public
input process from a permitting process
uh from a 10year plan process so um the
project in the 10e plan is Salem
43790 um it's currently under uh
design uh by a consultant uh
VHB um and it is a municipally managed
project which the town of Salem is
managing um so they are are currently
going through an Alternatives analysis
one of the Alternatives is a
signalization of the
intersection um the project is funded
through highway safety Improvement uh
program and currently in the schedule is
uh planned for construction um in March
of
2025 um the issue really for us is um
the predetermination that a signal is is
to be installed so we go through an
Alternatives analysis of what are the
POS possible options I mean that's
required for permitting for you know
Federal permitting State permitting um
you know to determine that we we just
don't say we're going to install this um
so that's part of our our our our review
our design um and the the process that
we
follow
the issue I think and why a roundabout
was um was sort of highlighted as the
solution
is the the
intersection and it's been the
reoccurring issue we have in previous
conversations the intersection doesn't
warrant a traffic signal as you know
through the design standards the mutcd
there are certain requirements for the
installation of a signal because a
signal installation unto itself creates
a
hazard so um there will be crashes
there'll be different crashes by
installing the signal so what we're
trying to do is make sure that the the
installation of the signal is is
warranted and I think that is one of the
issues as as was testified there are
alternative locations that people can go
down Armor Road to North Main Street and
on the other side there's connecting
roads to um the ha Road signal Iz
intersection just down the road and then
the Zachary Crossing intersection both
signalized so traffic does that today
and I I think you heard that testimony
traffic goes to those signalized
intersections to avoid this and I think
that traffic
volume is is the because the traffic
volume is in there it doesn't warrant a
a traffic
signal putting up a traffic signal um
when it's not warranted
frankly opens you up to
liability um uh you know if if you you
you put it in and and know and there's
crashes that occur and it was caused
because of the
signal you know somebody rear ends the
the the the queue somebody runs a red
light and there's crashes the first
thing that they're going to do is look
to see if if the you know any good
lawyer is going to look to see if
there's a a signal warrant analysis done
and if it doesn't S meet signal warrant
analysis um you know the the state would
be liable um so I I think that's some of
our concern um the the other concern is
is more technical um the effective date
being 30 60 days after passage um we're
assuming that that's when the design
would start um and not the installation
because um as as we put in the fiscal
note uh if we put in a traffic signal
the road needs to be widened it's one
lane in each direction to store the
traffic at the red light um the design
designers right now are calling for two
lanes in each Direction just to store
the traffic at the red light like you
see typically that will require a
RightWay
acquisition um so we would have to
acquire property um uh from the abuts to
be able to do that that's a lengthy
process so um if we started now um we're
probably talking
2026 until we would have a project to
design like I said the current project
is in 2025 so
um we don't see a
a you know a an advantage to creating a
new project and also the the other thing
is there's no funding associated with
this project so
um it's already in the 10-year plan so
there's funding ass associated with the
existing project this project there's no
no funding um we assumed that it would
be state funded and in the fiscal note
we note that there we don't have the you
know basically the $2 million to
spend in in betterment funds and State
uh Capital funds uh to do this so that
that's another issue so I will and that
thank you uh questions represent
pner can you explain what how what the
volume is on irmer road um and do you
have information what percentage left
turns versus right turns versus through
uh I do not I'm thinking that the safest
intersection here would be to prohibit
left turns and create the appropriate
islands that that is one of the options
to put a raised Island across the
intersection and make both sides right
in right out
only but thanks thank you rushar
you indicated that this project is in
the 10-year plan is that a project that
incorporates a
rotary nope it so all of our projects
come in sort of benign it's a safety
Improvement project so it will it it
includes all options so the consultant
would would look at any safety
Improvement um that you could do it in
intersection signal
roundabout um restricting turns um all
all those type of options are on on
board so we would look at those um you
know the the statistics that were shown
is we we would do a a benefit cost
analysis you know with these certain
installations we can we have historical
information that say you know if you
install this you're going to see this
type of safety Improvement you know the
the number of lives saved you know that
type of information so we do that
typically on all our projects that you
follow
up
so since this there's several options on
the table in the 10-year plan and one of
them would be a lighted intersection at
that point if it's chosen to be a
lighted
intersection then would that relieve the
state of the
responsibility because it would now
become warranted as you indicated
earlier it wasn't warranted would that
make it warranted and okay to build a
light no the the warrants are are
basically traffic volume created so you
have to have you know so many so many
left turns or right turns um versus the
through traffic so it it deals with the
people's inability to get out uh and and
onto the main road onto Route 11 in a
timely manner so those are all the
warrants that are based they're based on
peak hour they're based on you know
morning and evening commuting hours um
based on you know a bunch of various
different
scenarios so thank you repr Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
appearing um you you indicated one of
the Alternatives that would be analyzed
is signalized intersection I'm confused
about if we know that the signal
warrants aren't satisfied is that as
simple as oh the signal warrants aren't
satisfied that alternative is ruled
out typically yes because um if they're
not warranted
we would be very hesitant to installing
them because of the liability
issue thank you rip
boy thank you Mr chairman director
oldenberg thank you for for testifying
today um representative Sweeny testified
that the town of Salem is willing to
take on the signalization at this
intersection which would consequently
infers to me that they're willing to
accept the liability that that is
involved as it relates to whether they
choose to have a s signal warrant
analysis or not so is it is it my
inference that P excuse me the dot wants
if the light were to be put in there
that you want to retain ownership of
that we would typically I I believe we
would we own or maintain all of the
signals on
111 um so that's that's the first I've
heard the town's willing to take over
the ownership I I don't believe we would
be opposed to that um but I that that
enters into a Nuance
that you know I'm I'm not familiar with
and I think we would have to talk to the
town of Salem so that they they fully
understand um the responsibility and the
liability they'd be taking over followup
and then the followup I'm trying to
understand seven years from a
significant accident in 2016 to here we
are in 2024
and we're we're still discussing about
an improvement that both at least again
how I'm inferring the testimony from
yourself and from from my colleague
behind you that is for the lack of a
better word Frau with Peril so I'm
trying to understand how a process can
take seven years a collaborative process
between Dot and the town of s take seven
years to try and mitigate a a nuisance
intersection that creates certain
nightmares for for people trying to
negotiate that intersection can you
explain how dot Works processes as it
relates to intersection
mitigation that's a
very very complicated but what I mean we
have numerous
intersections with the same type of you
know crash history throughout the state
um we typically review them uh in the
past it was a the state traffic Eng
engineer um that would uh receive the
the you know receive the complaint uh
have the issue raised uh they would
typically go through and do a a signal
warrant analysis uh
because you know back at those in those
days and you know even seven years ago
um a a project like that would be run
through the traffic Bureau so they would
would review it they would um they would
do an analysis and and see whether meta
a signal warrant um a
project that came through um the 10-year
plan would have to come through the
regional planning commissions um and and
and that way um so that then it falls
into a priority a regional priority um
this project didn't meet that
requirement so it never came in the 10e
plan through our typical you know
Regional Planning Commission this came
through as a Safety project working
through our our safety section um more
or less a a road safety audit um review
um which was done I I don't have the
date but I'm assuming since this project
was funded and started several years ago
um that um it it it came in you know
probably three or four years ago into
the process it then gets added Ed into
our safety projects funded through hsip
that is a much faster uh process but um
not all projects uh do that um and it's
it's it's basically because
the um the intersection safety is is as
you've heard um not stellar and that
sort of popped it to the top of the list
from a highway safety um Improvement
section so that that's how it became a
project um and how it was
funded okay thank you short followup am
I allowed to make a comment or no I
would rather you don't I'll hold it hold
it for executive session I'll hold it
for executive session thank you okay and
I I just want to comment in um in my 20
years sitting in this room um I have
seen very many many projects of this
same um importance unfortunately taking
this long to make its way up to the top
uh re Sam
Newton thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question is there is
there open communication between your
department in the town of uh Salem with
us I mean are you guys really trying to
work together to let them know why this
is taking as long as it is and is there
any easy uh temporary fix to this
problem
I'll start with the communication so I'm
I'm I'm a little taken back um because I
mean this is in the 10-year plan we have
an agreement with the town of Salem
they' they'
hired uh VHB one of our best safety
Consultants to do this work that the
information we have came from them and
the work that they're doing um working
with the town of Salem so I'm I'm I'm
not sure why there's a there's a
communication disruption but um this is
not this is a do funded project that is
being run and managed by the town of
Salem so um I as
for I apologize an easy fix or temporary
easy fix um if we could do an easy fix
uh we would do it um I we sort of talked
about one of the easiest fixes when this
project came up is is disclosing the
road off making it right in right out
but that from a business standpoint
because there are businesses on the
corner that's sort of a an an a nogo for
for a lot of that so um I I think as an
easy no there there's not really an easy
we could go out tomorrow and do
something thank you represent
Melvin thank you Mr
chairman taking my question uh I'm
assuming that you've been involved in
quite a few roundabouts throughout the
state would you have any kind of an
estimate on the
cost it would it would probably be a
little bit more um than the signalized
intersection is we valued it at or
priced it out at about $1.6
million based upon historical review
roundabout I would I would tend to think
with the traffic volume on 111 it would
it would have two lanes on 111 one lane
on Irma Road so it' be a hybrid we those
are probably in the $2 million range um
so I it would be more expensive but
there's very little maintenance cost um
with a roundabout and it it it does um
reduce crashes uh tremendously compared
to a signal thank you followup followup
uh do you think that it would uh affect
any businesses that might be going in
that corner or be at that corner um it
it could um the the so with the if we
put in a signal the the the sketches of
the plans that we saw would be five
Lanes wide today it's it's
two um so or are three lanes wide so
there's a widening associated with the
signal the roundabout at the
intersection would probably be a little
bit wider um whether or not it would
impact future development I in in
looking at the existing businesses and
they appear to be far enough off from
the the road to not be impacted uh but
any future business I'm I'm not sure
that would go on the other sides thank
you any further
questions yes represent fuler question
is this a project eligible for federal
funding and is that at all uh in
Jeopardy if this does not meet signal
warrants um it well uh highway safety
Improvement money is federal money um
and if if it doesn't meet signal
warrants I I would believe we couldn't
fund it with Federal wary because they
they wouldn't allow us to to signalize
it I I would also add that we would I
believe that the Consultants you
wouldn't find a consultant that would
design a signal if it didn't meet once
uh so they would back out I would
believe um I don't think their legal
staff would would allow him to do that
um thank you any further
question seeing none thank you thank you
is there anyone that has spoken wishes
to speak a second time or anyone that
hasn't provide a testimony would like to
do it this time Reb Sam
Sweeney I just want to quickly thank the
dot for presenting here I want to make
it very clear this is not filed due to a
lack of communication with DOT they've
been great Partners in this project
reviewing the the traffic analysis this
was filed to really just State the
preference of the town of Salem for a
signalized intersection uh considering
the the traffic warrant and the analysis
that we've been going through with DOT
uh but just to to put at ease the
committee dot has been responsive
communicative I've been working with the
town on this as our preference is the
signalized intersection so thank you I
is it is it for a new piece of
information representative Newton please
thank you for taking my question um
would the city city be opposed to a
round of all there instead of a traffic
traffic light I my sense of what the of
the Town Council and the the
stakeholders and residents near the
intersection that we've talked to there
is severe apprehension about a
roundabout uh and there's a preference
towards a signal I
intersection thank you any further
questions please
brief represent
B thank you Mr chairman
um would the city be uh willing to
accept the outcome of the public
hearings because it sound like there's
still public hearings to be done on
setting up the preference of the
available uh
Alternatives uh that are set up for the
intersection absolutely the town of
Salem is going to work with doot and our
consultant on the signalized
intersection and just again for the
timeline for everyone this bill was
filed in November the the roundabout and
other Alternatives wasn't entered into
the discussion until the December Town
council meeting for our knowledge Point
um to our our R end in November when the
bill was filed the signalized
intersection was the altern was the the
solution to the the issue we're
obviously going to hear to public
concern and
hearings thank you uh I just if I could
while I have you here we had a we had a
similar issue before this board or this
committee uh a year or two ago on a on a
Conway intersection where the town
through the process wanted to make a
change um so uh I just want you to know
that we have heard this subject before
it didn't end the way that town wanted
but we have heard this so just for just
for your information I I appreciate that
and I I appreciate everything you're
balancing here on this Bill thank you
thank you for your uh your entry and do
we have any signatures on the blue
sheets representative
Newman sort of like the Academy Awards
what do we have
here there of all saying
um uh the we only have one signed in and
it's a gentleman bill from the
Department uh opposed with that we will
call to a
close uh the hearing for 1262 FN and I
would use my gabble if it was here it's
on the fourth floor thank you for your
time did you did you was our Gap still
there no I didn't find the
gap
oh sh
yeah
time being 10:45 I'd like to open up the
public hearing for House Bill 122
FN uh I will uh relative the issuance of
permits for the alteration of driveways
ex existing onto public ways I would
like to recognize the prime sponsor
representative Joe Alexander please come
forward and welcome to Public Works and
highways well thank you Mr chair
honorable colleagues members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Joe Alexander I represent Hillsboro
District 29 which is the town of
Goffstown um you may know or not know
that there was a very special Committee
created um at the beginning of last year
relative to housing um and the speaker
appointed me as chair um the committee
consisted of five Republicans and five
Democrats and the mission that we had
was to find um reasonable solution to
the housing crisis affecting our state
so with that um this is one of the bills
that has resulted from the committee and
it came to Public Works and highways
because this has to do a lot with public
works and highways so um with further
Ado um in the special committee
specifically we entertain listening to
developers Property Owners planning
board members Realtors I mean the whole
Gambit like when you talk about the
housing crisis it really was everybody
um you know landlords um tenants tenant
rights groups everybody and one of the
things that came about it was the idea
that a lot of State permitting takes
longer than in some in some ways people
would anticipate it should take um so
special committee we heard from
developers and homeowners alike that
when a developer makes an application
for a permit to do it takes some cases
six months or so to sign off on the
permit so this bill um would put a
reasonable timeline in place of 30 days
for most cas in 45 days as defined under
section three of the bill so section
three would be the um commercial
industrial Enterprise or subdivision so
um so dot considers any roadway that
intersects with a highway as a driveway
so municipalities also have to deal with
this sort of thing um when a
municipality tries to put a Road
intersecting with a state highway so
that's also what would apply under this
bill um so pering by so there's three
reasons why you should really vote for
this bill um it incentivized do to work
more collaborative
collaboratively together with applicants
who include the developers Property
Owners
municipalities and you would support
property rights by ensuring that there
are reasonable timelines in place to
move forward with projects and you'd be
moving the ball in the right direction
on the housing crisis I think putting
reasonable timelines on the department
to issue permits they issue about 1,00
permits a year I think that um that is
completely reasonable to go Within a
30-day timeline um you'll hear from the
commissioner who probably will or
someone from the Department who probably
outline the process a little bit more um
but I believe even with the es and flows
of the permitting process I believe that
this is a completely reasonable bill um
that will help give a more concrete
timeline for people that apply for
driveway permitting that could be people
towns developers Etc so um I also have
excuse me I passed around an amendment
that removes the planning board from
this um timeline process defined in the
bill so um this amendment is supported
by nhma um who I've also circulated
their letter it would basically only
apply to dot um but you'll find in most
cases municipalities don't take nearly
as long to sign off on permits um but
with that I'm happy to take questions
about housing process that kind of thing
but um I think you should support the
Bill thank you with the with the
amendment yes um representative
voy thank you Mr chairman representative
Alexander thank you for your testimony I
appreciate it turning to what I guess
would be page one of your bill section
two lines 10 and 11 we have 30 days and
we have within 45 days and my notation
is 30 days of what or 45 days of what
and my question would be we talking the
application yes so it's um it it says on
line S a written construction permit
application must be so from what I read
it's must be obtained and filed by the
department so once that's filed I
believe the 30-day window starts then um
so the 30 days has to do with most
permits and then the 45 it goes to
commercial industrial and apply
Enterprise or subdivision okay so I I
follow up Mr chair so I agree with you I
just do we want to consider clarifying
that down below or are you comfortable
with line seven provides the
amplification necessary to um magnify
the 30 days and the 45 days I believe
it's pretty straightforward um there are
I believe there's only one member other
than me of the special committee on
housing represented makoni was on the
committee as well when we actually
looked at specifically at this language
last year before we introduced it as a
bill and um I I'm pretty confident that
this language makes it pretty clear
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman further question representative
pulner please so my understanding is
that the department won't look at an
application until after the Project's
been through site plan review and has
received a sign off on the final
design uh because that might change
during the site plan review
process is there a minimum time I mean
if if if the information is not complete
and somebody submits a application early
should the department be able to hold
off until the the design is finalized by
the site plan review process that's a
great question thank you representative
um I see I read written construction
permit as a completed written
construction permit um so I believe that
that wouldn't apply until the
application is entirely completed and
the process has gone through and then
you'll find
um look there's language in this bill
that allows the opportunity for um a
negotiating process between a permitter
and do to make sure that there's a
reasonable timeline if if they can't
meet the 30 days dot can go to the
developer and say we can't meet this
30-day can you give us x amount more
time and they would award that time
hopefully thank you further
questions president Mill do you have
something oh I'm sorry representative
Abbott thank you for that yes thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um does as I recall when we
considered a similar bill before there
was a um a question raised about what if
there is a change in the
development does that provide a window
for the transportation
do so um I'm going to defer the question
because I'm not entirely sure of that so
I'm gonna pass that
on thank you further
question um for the representative um
it was a pleasure of course serving on
that committee and uh and I know the
governor and um and other departments
are anxious to speed along the process
especially with housing for uh for the
state um but I want to bring the
conversation back to the issuing of uh
driveway permits and I had brought this
point up before your location and where
you are in the state can be a Factor on
how
quick permits are
provided I live in a Northern Mo section
and permits happen in in a regular
timely basis there are there are some
areas that are south of me and west of
me that it just seems to take longer
every time to do
that um I'm not disc disparaging dot
officials or what whatever but I I and
the issue that was brought forward by a
lot of developers and trying to bring
big projects forward is at that time
even elapses and makes it extremely more
difficult so um what am I correct in my
in my assumption of what I heard during
those public hearings yes Mr chair that
was um what I what I understand the
conversation to be about as well is that
there's a discrepancy on different parts
of the state and the timeline it takes
thank you any further questions seeing
none thank you
representative um I will I tried to jump
you into last hearing Ben Frost would
you please come forward New Hampshire
housing thank you Mr chairman and good
morning committee members my name is Ben
Frost I'm the deputy executive director
and chief legal officer at New Hampshire
house
we're not normally before this committee
so I'll just give you two seconds of of
who we are and what we do we're not a
state agency we are a public
instrumentality of the state created by
the legislature in
1981 uh for the purpose of doing among
other things uh financing the
development and uh long-term asset
management of multif family uh housing
rental housing and some that's something
we do on an annual basis all over the
state so we don't we don't build we
don't own the housing but we Finance it
and as a financing entity uh we
recognize that for developers and I
would say in particular for developers
of uh affordable housing time really is
money for affordable housing developers
it's it's money that they cannot pass on
to the end user the the renters because
uh the rents are controlled uh their
profit is controlled uh so it's
something that they absorb uh the cost
of delays
so whenever there is a delay from any
Source uh that is costly for developers
of uh all types of housing but in
particular for affordable housing uh for
that reason uh we are in support of
House Bill
122 and thank representative Alexander
for uh introducing it uh I I'll note a
couple things and representative
Alexander uh did talk about the the
ability of uh the department to
negotiate with with applicants uh
there's also the opportunity for the
Department to say no if an application
is incomplete and they're coming up
against the 30 or 45 day deadline they
can say we're denying this application
it is it is incomplete uh and and that's
really the onus is on the applicant to
present complete and final information
to the department uh and then for the
Department to be able to review that um
I I recognize that 30 and 45 days is a
it's a number uh is that the right
number I don't know exactly uh but I
think that for applicants to public
agencies to have some reasonable idea of
how long something is going to take is
not an unreasonable request uh and I
think that that's incumbent upon any
public
agency um with regard to the amendment
and this is I'm speaking to Amendment
0470 um this is designed to align
with existing perit deadlines that
planning boards already deal with so if
you look at the Planning and Zoning
statutes uh planning boards are required
once they accept jurisdiction of an
application they're required to come to
a final decision on subdivision or site
plan applications within 65 days that is
a statutory time frame uh so this is a
time frame that is very familiar to
local planning boards and by extension
if they're if they're uh delegating that
responsibility to say a local DPW uh
then the time would also apply there um
I'd be happy to take any questions but
again we support this build with the
amendment any questions yes please
R so if it could take up to 65 days to
get a completed application through the
planning board at that point they would
apply for a permit and then their 30 or
45 day whichever is uh applicable would
then start because you now have signed
off
prints thank you for the question and
let me clarify this um the Dot's role is
for Access permits on state highways
Municipal action on driveway permits is
only on Municipal highways that is class
five and class six highways uh so those
are two separate processes on state
highways dos jurisdiction on Town
highways the town has jurisdiction the
planning board has jurisdiction by
Statute so there would be no additional
process on a Town Highway once the town
grants the access permit if the the the
property owner has the
permit oh followup
please as for a state highway then would
it be
different uh great question
representative uh there the section and
I'm I'm talking about the the bill is
introduced page two lines 18 through 30
um that is the local process uh and that
is different from the uh planning board
role with site plan and subdivision
review so typically let's say you have a
a development that's on a state highway
uh the property owner knows the
developer knows that they're going to
have to go to do at some point uh to get
an access permit but they're not going
to do that until they know what it is
the planning board is approving because
the planning board board may say no we
want your driveway over there even
though the department May disagree and
ultimately it is it it is up to the
department to say where those things go
and that might be some matter of
negotiation that involves the developer
and the town and the department uh so
that that can take some time if for
let's say um in this came up in an
earlier question let's say a planning
board approves a site plan for a
commercial development or for a
residential development and it has a a
sh driveway shown on the the approved
site
plan the applicant the property owner
then the developer then goes to the
department for a driveway permit and the
and the department says no we can't put
it there for these reasons it has to go
here then it's up to the property owner
the developer to go back to the planning
board and and get an amendment to that
approval uh typically speaking uh that
well that's a fairly common process uh
but it does oftentimes say a planning
board will uh give an approval subject
to the Department's uh issuance of an
access permit and so they they may come
back uh at some later point with the
changes made by the
department thank you further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
chairman
um Tom is it Jose I'm
sorry housing action New
Hampshire good morning Mr chairman good
morning members of the committee uh my
name is Tom do roza uh I serve as the
engagement Communications manager uh for
housing action New Hampshire we're here
support of this uh bill before you uh
had a chance to review the amendment we
support the amendment as well as Mr
Frost just stated oh let me back up
housing action New Hampshire uh we are a
member organization we have over 80
members that's made up of uh nonprofit
for-profit developers uh housing
financers uh service providers children
and family advocates and so we have a
common goal of coming together and
ensuring that uh we can work to improve
state and federal policy so that
everybody has a place to call home uh so
with that and with this bill brought
forward by representative Alexander from
the special committee on housing we
would support this because as Mr Frost
stated uh it's not our our members any
delay cannot necessarily easily absorb
those costs so if we can see this as a
way of getting more units online and
getting more people housed we are uh in
support of it be happy to attempt to
answer any questions thank you uh
questions Mr
Rose thank you for
attending um I would like to call
Department of Transportation Michaels
and I apologize
sir welcome to Public Works and highways
once
again good morning chairman and members
of the committee um just for the record
my name is Mike citus I am the director
of operations for the Hampshire
Department of Transportation and um
thank you for taking my testimony
regarding this uh this bill the
department is committed to providing
customer service in uh processing
driveway applications as efficiently and
uh timely as possible however timeliness
of the application is really uh not
entirely upon the Department's you know
control um a lot of the um the control
is really with the applicant to provide
um the completeness of the documentation
which is outlined in the driveway policy
the department processes approximately
1100 driveway permits annually and the
number of major entrance permits which
would include subdivisions uh is
somewhere between two to 7% of that
annual number the department approves
more than 85% of their requests in under
60 days the ones that take longer are
generally the larger projects which
require traffic impact studies or some
kind of mitigation work which needs to
be done and approved before the
construction approval can be given the
department must oppose hb12 VES two
which in our opinion does not provide
the department or the applicant
sufficient time to work through the
numerous steps in the design review
process our belief that while the
existing process May in some cases take
more time and resources than the
applicant wants the time is Justified to
protect the safety mobility and the
investment the state the state has made
in the transportation system RSA
23613 requires written construction
permit to be obtained by the
commissioner of the Department of
Transportation prior to any construction
or alteration in the public way the goal
is to provide safe and efficient
operating environment for everybody that
uses the state transportation system in
order to define the uniform application
for review and process throughout the
state the commissioner of the Department
of Transportation issued declaratory
ruling uh number
2000-1 back in March
2 this is the policy for the permitting
of driveways and other accesses to the
state highway which is known as the
driveway per uh the driveway manual
copies of this can be found on do
website along with other uh information
such as the permit and how to uh fill
out the
permit section one of this manual
basically outlines the the purpose
providing uniform procedures throughout
the state for the processing issuance of
a driveway permit application in
accordance with the following
promote the safety and protection of the
traveling public through orderly control
of traffic movement minimize conflict
points verify appropriate site distance
of class one and two State highways
maintain serviceable uh serviceability
on effective highways monitor design and
construction of driveways and
maintenance of RSA
um rules said in another way the purpose
of the driveway policy is to protect the
state's investment in our transportation
system by providing access it will not
only erode the safety and efficiency of
the existing transportation system
within the requirements of the law
current engineering
standards basically safety and Corridor
management is critical in providing a
safe and efficient transportation system
to move Mo people movement in
Goods unfortunately all driveways and
access points create safety and mosil IL
issues number one driveways introduce
conflict points which degrade safety
mobility and serviceability of the road
for through
traffic second speed differentials and
turning movements are increased which
also increases the potential for
crashes in order to promote the safety
and uh Mobility what we try to do is
restrict the number and location of
these conflict
points um it was known or we' noted that
applications for single family residents
small traffic generators make up the uh
by far the largest group of uh
applications we get these applications
are normally processed just through the
information provided on the forms and
the supplemental information which is
basically demonstrating the history of
the parcel since
1971 which provides you know through
relevant deeds and then taking a look at
the safe site uh site distance at the
propos osed location these are normally
processed in less than 30 days in um
unless there's an issue with um the the
process to which the parcel was made or
some locations they cannot achieve the
safe site distance of 400 feet in either
direction application reviews for
subdivisions of commercial businesses
which include residential subdivisions
uh are more
complex they're covered section six and
there are um essentially a few more uh
areas that need to be included within
that
application basically you're going to
get six major Milestones which are going
to require engineering and design
leading up to the construction approval
the first one uh the major step is
submission of that application the
second is setting up a scoping meeting
scoping meetings are done are held with
state stakeholders and basically to uh
identify issues in the transportation
Network in the vicinity of that proposed
development stakeholders include the
Department of Transportation the Highway
Maintenance District uh traffic Bureau
and Highway design it also includes the
applicant the municipality and planning
agencies in the
area we do encourage uh municipalities
to attend these scoping meetings because
we don't like to wait until the end to
coordinate with the uh municipalities
because what can happen which was
discussed is they go ahead and they
approve a development with a an access
point that is after that is approved is
the first time we see an application
come in and it's in an area that uh
either doesn't meet site distance um it
may require offsite improvements that
impact other private land that they
cannot get easement do at which point
they can't do the mitigation so um we
prefer to be brought in or discussed
these issues and citing locations early
in the process not at the
end traffic uh there's a stage where you
get the traffic impact study part of the
scoping meeting is to define the formal
requirements of the traffic impact
study traffic inpact study basically
will will go through and this is
generally where they hire a traffic
engineer to to determine what the trip
generation is going to be how that trip
those trips are assigned throughout the
study area network they take a look at
the operability does the uh additional
um uh traffic degrade any of the
intersection operations is it going to
have a impact of the safety on any of
the areas um that they find or is there
a known safety impact already in that
area that this might aggravate
um and it also we we'll take a look at U
look at ways of mitigating any of those
impacts once the next big step is once
the department agrees with the findings
and the um modeling of that traffic um
traffic study is they really move on to
that mitigation stage is what is it if
anything that the development needs to
do to mitigate their traffic impacts on
that on the state
system once this this these traic
impacts could be um something like just
putting out signing could be adding a
roundabout could be looking at a traffic
signal could be minor impacts uh
widening of shoulders um or it could be
adding auxiliary Lanes you know the the
larger the development usually the
larger the impact they have and that's
where we start getting into to some of
these mitigation plans can be quite
extensive and again we view that any
kind of uh construction on the state
highway system really needs to conform
to the state's uh standards and design
practices because ultimately it becomes
part of the state
infrastructure once there's an an
agreement on the 30% plan what is the uh
required
mitigation the applicant then um
generates 30% design plan plans and
these document what the uh what is going
to be required to support that um that
development from the within the state uh
RightWay system at this point the
department um is looking at uh allowing
or issuing a conditional approval
similar to what local local improvements
can do or local authorities can do but
it's it's not a construction approval
but it does basically say the department
is is in agreement with what is going to
be provided uh or constructed out there
and once all the plans uh easements
permits uh in bonding is set up there
will be issued the construction
permit it's understood that you know
these larger projects can take
significant amount of time um it takes a
lot of engineering time to provide pres
prepare the plans and the studies it
takes a lot of time time for the
department or through their Consultants
to review them
um we probably and and we're probably
not telling anything new but you know
our
our number of applications has increased
40% over the last five years in that
same time frame we've lost 25% of our
engineering staff this is really uh
changed our our I guess our our process
that we are relying a lot more more on
the consultant Community to do our uh
reviews and um that kind of
turnaround the consultant Community
isn't doing a lot better than we are um
on on folks on engineering staff so that
has not exactly changed the amount of
time it is taking to process these in
addition when you send these out to the
Consultants you still need to have an
internal review to get consistency
because what we don't want to do is send
out plans in one section of the state
using one consultant that has a
different Viewpoint than another so what
we try to do is come up with some kind
of consistency in our reviews the other
part is we have reviews by Highway we
have reviewed by the uh Traffic Division
and we'll have reviewed by maintenance
before we submit comments back to an
applicant or an engineer we want to make
sure that we give them One Direction on
that because we may have multiple
internally multiple ideas on what should
be done so these all take
time let's see I will say that we we
have been engaged for for some time and
uh I'm trying to come up with ways to
speed along and make this process more
transparent um over the last year we
have been engaged with working on the
state permit tracking system um this is
a initiative that's trying to get all
the state permits to be in one location
uh our choice to uh to to really start
the system for for the dot was the
driveway permit that is the most
important permit uh that we want to try
to get handle and move along so we we
are making slow progress but the idea is
to to find a syst system where it's
easier to transmit and receive
information from the applicants the
engineers and also make it more
transparent where the process is who's
who's got the review who's got the ball
at that time that becomes a big
issue um I guess in conclusion um
because I'm probably taking up too much
time as as it is um the department
understands there may be times when the
applicants feel that we're we're taking
too much time on this however the
department sees its role is really
protecting the safety and Mobility for
the public and the investment that the
state has been making in this
transportation
system the review process really focuses
on three things one number one the
nature and traffic demand generated by a
development seeking access to the state
highway number two the impact that
development will have on the existing
state highway system number three how do
we how do we mitigate any adverse
impacts while not perfect the department
is working hard to review the driveway
permit application as quickly as
possible admittedly with limited people
this is a difficult task but we are
looking for other Alternatives you know
to speed the process along unfortunately
some of our emergency responses to storm
and infrastructure failures are also
done by the same people who do the
permitting reviews so that tends the
slowest down a
bit we look for cooperation willingness
together with the developers the
developers engineers in the department
to look to come up with a way to make it
uh the process quicker and more
efficient the department does not
believe that the public would be uh
served better by putting in or
instituting strict uh time limits
because I think what you're going to
find is there going to be a lot more
denials and that's ultimately going to
slow the process down
and then uh we did put in there that as
a part of the fiscal note you know if we
were going to try to come up and hit
those or or meet some of those timelines
what the uh the cost would be um
unfortunately I think even if funded you
know we could uh I don't think we could
fill the positions um just looking at
the last three years of of trying to
fill positions we we currently have so
um again that's that's kind of Our
Testimony and I'll be happy to answer
anybody's questions thank you um if if
the committee would indulge me I'd like
to start here so
um 40% increase in in
permitting um Staffing being down 25% I
I every Department in the state uses
that exact same figure where your
department environmental services
subsurface Wetlands everything else
everyone else Consultants everybody body
else is operating on that um would you
believe and then I'll continue on
Department of Environmental
Services um I'm going to say 20 years
ago uh if you were if you were to um
submit a an individual application for a
septic Disposal system or a septic
system that they had on on the books
that they had they had 30 days to um to
approve or disapprove an application
the department for some reason when
there was no issue with with number of
personnel would take sit on them for 30
days issue a letter that it was
incomplete and then people would go back
in a cycle it was holding up individual
homeowners consistently it was a problem
that was addressed and Department of
Environmental Services you had mentioned
some things about trying to get these
things online they they they led the
cause on these things their turnaround
time is to two days now building a
septic system is not building a highway
or trying to figure out how to get an
off I don't mean to make that
correlation but sometimes when a time
frame is put in place uh as my father
would say it would get my fanny moving
so and I have nothing but the respect
for your department I I need to say that
um
perhaps um and this would be a question
for the sponsor and maybe I could have
the sponsor address this after uh if I
if I look at the the
LSR and I get down to uh line 20 of the
first page under section three for
Access of a proposed commercial
industrial Enterprise or a
subdivision let's let's say I was to
adopt the position of the department
that this is too broad for this amount
of time with the amount of Personnel I
had I'm wondering if you have some idea
how many of the applications or could
get back to myself or the U sponsor how
many of these
applications are for housing
developments or a multi-use development
which would have possibly some
commercial with a lot of apartments and
so forth on it and for my argument of
sake it would be a a subdivision that
would have over 70% component of housing
to it if if this were and I know you
can't answer this right now or maybe you
could offer an opinion uh if if this if
there was a section of this that that
ask the the department to be under this
time frame for this specific item uh I'm
again I'm I'm assuming this isn't a huge
amount but when I when I look at the
charge that the speaker gave to to the
um to the special task force the
governor's position on this and if the
governor were to weigh in uh would that
make this process any easier for the
Department that's a good question and
and I think what you're if I can kind of
paraphrase it what you're asking is if
we separate out residential subdivisions
from other larger generators and you
know looking at uh the traffic
generation for residential it's it's not
quite as um on on the peak hours it's
lower uh we don't generally see as as
much um mitigation so that may move
things quicker um so that it it would be
a help and I think that' be worth
exploring better I think that would
be that would that would be a better fit
uh when you cast that bigger net that
that really causes some consternation so
and I can get back with you and take a
look at as far as the housing over the
last year so thank thank you sir
questions represent fauler thank you
thank you for the taking the question
following up on Chairman's question gave
the example of
subsurface U discharge
permits and Dees I my understanding is
from many classes of these permits they
basically take the findings of a uh or
the design of a licensed
subservice uh
disposal um
consultant and issue a permit almost
automatically is there a parallel here I
mean can you trust the um or accept the
the designs of licensed civil engineers
on on these projects you know if they
meet your meet your standards instead of
having to redo or re review every single
project at that level of detail
thank you for the question um you know
we do require the designs to be done by
professionals and as a PE you can only
work within your area of expertise uh we
do rely more on you know whether it's a
traffic engineer that has that expertise
particularly at
ptoe um or the designers but we still
need to review them to um to meet our
standards there is a difference um a lot
of the engineer are used to more working
you know outside of the state RightWay
where there's a little more leeway um we
we tend to to focus a little harder
because um if there's a problem it's the
state that has to fix it you know we're
the ones that have to maintain it we're
a lot more uh particular in how things
are built because of that because
there's a public investment into it um
yes we do rely more on on on the
engineers and what they bring up um but
as with most things there's a lot
of discussion and debate particularly
when you get into trip generation you
know we try to make that pretty or the
engineering community tries to make that
fairly straightforward but there's
always a bit of a debate so um again I
think we're moving those things faster
through there but there's always going
to be some a review component to
that
represent Jack uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for appearing I still have my
copy of the driveway policy from the
last time someone brought a hard
deadline bill um it seems like the
process for a complex development is
just plain going to take longer than 30
or 45 days is there a number that the
department would be willing to commit to
uh or is that just not not a thing that
could
happen thank you for the question the
we've been kind of trying to work on
that
it's I guess the traffic world is is
really related in very well to the the
real estate world it's really the
location that dictates you know you can
have a smaller generator on a road that
has 12,000
Vehicles a day being as as critical for
us to look at is you've got a generator
of 600 vehicles but it's on a road that
only has 500 Vehicles a day it's it's
really that location that we have to
take a look at we've been trying to
figure out a way
to I guess categorize things similar to
looking at maybe we separate out the
residentials is looking at uh traffic
generators and not only looking at the
number that they generate but that trip
end generation but also recognizing
what's the volume of traffic on the road
in somehow better equating what our
requirements are um to that what we've
looked at in a few places is taking a
look at uh if it's not a a large
generator is maybe just documenting the
traffic through a memo so that we know
okay we're going to
approve uh a five seat restaurant and
somebody doesn't open up a Dunkin'
Donuts on it which is completely
different so unfortunately the only way
we have currently to do that is going
through the full traffic impact study
and going through it but those are some
of the areas we're trying to come up
with that that that can maybe speed the
process
over thank you um yes please represent
jurus thank you Mr
chairman currently in the review of the
driveway permits especially for the
housing is there overtime for for some
of the in with your engineering staff
and any other technical staff for
instance maybe on I suggest but Saturday
or something or after hours during the
week to help review and in addition uh
do you have civil engineering or other
engineering um interns from local
universities that work for the
Department as well who could maybe pitch
in in this effort to in the review
process yeah thank you for the question
the um
yeah pretty much I hate to say it you
know in the legislative building but
overtime is pretty much if if they're
willing we are willing to to move them
along um you know being down so many
people that's not impacting our budget
so much so we we are willing to
entertain any of them um intern wise we
have been able to start grabbing more
interns we are trying to get as many as
we can they don't fill quite the area
for the reviews but what we can backfill
um because again one of our problems are
we don't have dedicated people that are
going to do the traffic or Highway
reviews uh right now but being down that
we have to steal somebody who is
probably working on a federal project so
that's kind of when they find so what we
fig can try to do is get the interns to
maybe take some of their work some of
the the I I hate this word the grunt
work you know cross-sections or
something like that but then to maybe
free up some time for the more senior
people to backfill us but right now the
the our biggest U opportunity is we've
been trying to lean on the Consulting uh
Engineers unfortunately you know like I
said they're they're feeling the pinch
with getting Engineers as
well thank you further question
represent
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and mrvz
thank you very much for your testimony
you had indicated in your conclusion
that and please correct me if I if I'm
misquoting you that you focus on traffic
demand impacts and mitigation when
looking at driveway permits is that
correct yeah pretty much yes okay follow
up Mr chair yes please the the issue
that I'm struggling with is that you're
adding a duplicative process that's
already done at the local level and
having sat on my local planning board
for close to 10 years we address those
same very issues when when assessing a
piece of property whether it be whether
it be multif family use to marac Premium
Outlets which I know you're probably
very familiar with we my community has
run the gamut so my question is with
your processes how many times let me
rephrases what is the percentage where
the state has stepped in and has
undercut local jurisdiction on these
particular decisions and you've sent the
applicant back to a particular
municipality to review the issue yeah
thank you very much for the question um
this is the reason why we try to get
involved early you know we work hard to
stay out of the realm
of uh outside the RightWay that's the
jurisdiction of the towns we try to stay
out what we try to focus in on is okay
if that particular
development generates so much traffic we
need to take a look at what that impact
is just within the the uh roadway system
and that's where we look at the
mitigation we would prefer to have that
discussion with the towns um where we
can which which we you know what we
ultimately strive for but you know
realistically we just basically you know
we don't try to dictate what they can
build on that property it's once that's
that's decided on and what that
traffic's generated that's when we look
at it is what happens when that traffic
gets out on to the state highway
system follow up thank you Mr chairman
so in in that particular aspect is there
any
particular prohibition
rule with do that would
prevent any any applicant coming to a
municipality going to need a driveway
basically a curve cut that it's going to
need a curve cut pinit to utilize the
scoping meeting in advance to begin the
process sooner than later so that based
on my my colleague's propos rule that
the eyes are daughter the teas across
the eggs are in one basket and that the
30-day to 45 day rule might actually
make sense if if applicant in a
particular community that rely upon a
state roadway can utilize the scoping
meeting meeting to their Advantage yeah
but we would encourage them to come you
know as many people to come to that
scoping meeting just to set that that
stage
up thank you thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh represent
Newman yes thank you how many people are
on your engineering staff right
now have to get back to you on that one
um uh are you talking within operations
or are you
talking dist state
do I'm I'm just looking for the number
when you had said that you've got 25%
loss of your engineering staff I'm I'm
looking like how many people are we
talking I can I can get back to you oh
there's still left I'll have to get back
to on that number because what we what
we look at is the number up in project
development which that would be Bill
oldenberg who was here before he's on
that side um on mine I can tell you that
our engineer um we were without a
assistant District engineer in District
5 which was out of uh bow does a self
Center we were out with him for six
months they've been out without a uh
engineer that does our
uh is an accessing utilities engineer he
does the driveway permits uh we've been
with that F we just filled after two
years uh the a the guy that does the uh
field reviews that position's been
vacant for a year that's just in one
District so engineering wise I would say
we in operations are probably around 30%
short
upstairs I'll have to get the numbers
for you so you followup
yes thank you when if you have to go to
a consultant to take care of work are
they paid the same as your regular
people no they're paid under the
consultant their fees so so they
whatever the the Consulting that you
know they they ended up they put in for
a Statewide contract we have several
engineering contracts throughout the
department operations
we hadn't had them till I think about
two years ago was the first time we
started getting those because we needed
people um these are put out um through
project development but that they set
their their fee structure going through
the contract so no they we pay them at
their rates thank you thank you
represent uh further questions represent
Boer two part
question how long would you say a
traffic study would take is one part of
the question and number two if a local
planning board has made the requirement
of a traffic study does the state accept
that traffic
study so that it doesn't have to
duplicate the Su study
again um thank you for the question uh
traffic
study
um try to think back
um probably well you've got to get you
know time of year is tough if right now
to go out and track count traffic is a
little difficult because you know you've
got to get in between storms you don't
have really good data if particularly
let's say say you're doing a project on
Route One down in Hampton you're not
getting the same type but we can equate
that kind of time so um generally they I
think most engineering firms could if
they focused on it right within a couple
weeks you could generate it um again
that's F putting them in between what
other and what size um that's a that's a
big one uh in New Hampshire we generally
look at uh oper looking at operations
the driveway and potentially if they're
close by the intersection either side so
there's not a lot of generating work or
or evaluation work but you know that
that's you know I hate to speak for
other engineering firms but just going
back in my my past that that's probably
the best I could do is come up with
about three three to four weeks um can
we take from a planning board yes I mean
we would take a look at it because they
maybe again they may be looking at from
a little bit different point of view
than us but again if we could meet at
the uh scoping study before or while
they're going through the planning board
process and come up with one study that
meets most needs yeah I I would highly
encourage
that thank you uh any further
questions thank you for your time thank
you very much I'd like to bring forward
Jason sock New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association welcome to public
works thank
you I
uh hadn't plan on speaking um
specifically on this bill I did sign in
in support of it uh for the record Jason
stock New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association I think I was here last week
talking driveways are U yeah class six
roads our we have forestry operation
there are about 2 to 3,000 Timber
harvests that occur across the state
every year some of those access the
access point is off a state road and
when we when our policy committee saw
this
bill they they they endorsed it because
what we're seeing and what we're
observing is
inconsistency in getting a driveway
permit um and it it can vary from
districts and I think what you had heard
from probably the fire speaker that may
do be due to Staffing things of that
nature but if you're planning a Timber
Harvest particularly at sensitive times
of the year such as now when you have
weather changing and you're trying to
plan and say all right I've got to get
my Crews ready to go what's my timetable
look like if you have a permit or if you
if you're waiting on a driveway permit
that can take and it's a big question
mark I spoke to a couple contractors
it's been two months since they've heard
anything or seen anything it gets
disruptive so whether the number is 30
45 some certainty is really beneficial
because that provides some
planning um we get their their temporary
permits for for Timber harvesting and
it's a specific document and we we
appreciate that many times you're
entering off of an area that you use 15
years ago 10 years ago designs pretty
much the same logging trucks haven't
evolved a whole lot in the last 10 to 15
years and so what when I spoke to do
about this issue last fall um we were
kind of anxious and excited to hear that
there might be a online permitting
process where I say I'm a Forester and I
did a Timber sale off of Route 16 here
was the road I here's the access road I
could just basically either reference
that submit it and almost have an online
process unless something has
changed but um we haven't again we're
waiting to hear on that I think you had
heard there is some effort going on
within the department to try and at
least create a transparency on a
timetable but right now the situation
that we're facing and we're wrangling
with is this you know uncertainty you
find file file an application and it
kind of goes into a black box and when
they call the engineer they'll say I'll
get to it when I get to
it all right I've got I've got a half
dozen guys that want to get out and and
move onto that job what do I tell them
so again I'm happy to work with the
committee if there's efforts to look at
this bill look at this concept and say
all right this isn't the construction of
a large marac Shopping Center
this is an access it's an access that's
been used in the past we're going to do
the exact same thing maybe you kind of
create some criteria and some categories
but happy to work with the Department
with you folks on that again I just
wanted to raise that because sitting
here in the audience all I'm hearing
about is single family homes shopping
centers Dunkin Donuts well there's
another world out there and that's
Timber cutting some of that does access
state roads we are subject to driveway
permits and I think the permits
generally work but they don't always
work in terms of timing and so in as
much as we can provide some certainty
that would be
appreciated I'm not an expert on this
there are others that are I'm happy to
try and answer any questions and I
appreciate your your time this morning
thank you thank you questions for Mr
stock thank you thank
you I believe that is all the pink cards
I have um if we could get the blue sheet
sent forward are there any sponsor or
anyone who testified would like an
opportunity to speak a second time would
the sponsor take a question from the
chair
absolutely um repres I had asked a
question of the department if if the
scope of this
LSR were to U be restricted a little
more than it is right now and it seemed
in
just a global view that that might U
make might make a difference I'm
wondering if we might expect after uh
this is an early bill for us that we
need to get out I don't need to get it
out today I'm wondering if the sponsor
may consider a change uh you don't need
to commit to anything but I would just
like to have some
direction um that might be something we
could talk about other than inm
study yes so short answer thank you for
the question the answer is yes I think
that this the reason this bill was filed
was to deal with maybe perhaps some of
these larger subdivisions not being
approved at a reasonable time um so if
dot can get back to us with the data in
a reasonable time then we can kind of
look at that um I'm certainly open to it
but again again this is now the
committee's bill um so I'm happy to
defer to the committee if they prefer
Thank you Rich
Boer thank you Mr
chairman
um if the default happens and the permit
is forced to be
issued and then there's a turns up
there's a design
flaw and an accident happens
in legal r ramification happens who is
the state on the hook for that is the
local municipality on the hook for
that who's on the hook thank you for the
question there's language in here saying
that dot is allowed to say that they
haven't had reasonable time to look at
this permit yet so um I believe that in
that case they wouldn't be held
responsible because they said they
haven't had time to look into
it thank you representative um I anyone
else wish to testify a blue card seeing
none I have um our signup sheet here uh
Gary Abbott from the associated general
contractors welcome signs in and support
and Jason stock we have heard from uh
signs in and support I will uh I will
terminate I will end um House Bill
session or House Bill 122
[Music]
FN thank you one and all committee our
next
um our next hearing is at
1:15 House Bill
1468 I believe we're going to have a bit
of a audience so if everyone could be
back and in seats for 115 I would
appreciate that uh we're in recess till
then uh happy to take any questions
comments in between otherwise uh we will
see you back in your seats for
okay the time being 1
I will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 1468 and I will call upon the
Bill's Prime sponsor representative uh
Jonathan Smith to open it up thank you
for coming to Public Works and highways
today representative thank you Mr
chairman and thank you fellow
Representatives um I just want to open
up with I have a committee actually I
passed a package out manila folder to
everybody which has broad community
support and testimony from uh economic
councils snowmobile clubs Municipal
boards Etc and they also have a small
explanation of the rail bed that we are
discussing within this package okay on
behalf of the committee representative I
appreciate this folder will help us a
lot please continue thank you um so upon
introduction of this bill uh there's
been some changes in the idea because a
master plan would not really work so I
have an amendment that everyone has in
front of them it's amendment number
0530 it it replaces the bill and
entirety and I would uh respectfully ask
that the committee would consider it
okay and I just to be sure I don't mean
to interrupt everybody have a copy this
amendment right that he just said all
right okay again please continue it was
placed on top of the midd okay good all
right thank you so I'm gonna I have a if
the chairman will indulge me I have a a
one minute read I would just like to
read just about the back the background
of where we got here absolutely go ahead
so my name is Jonathan Smith I represent
the great people of oopy in Carol County
District 5 I am also the chairman of the
board of Selectmen the bill before you
is an extremely important step in
bringing progress to the town of oopy
the rail bed also known as the Conway
Branch or Corridor 19 to the snowmobile
Community is a gigantic asset that
traverses the town I as both a
representative and selectman have been
working with an organization called Fort
friends of Osby rail trail whose purpose
is to revitalize and enhance the quality
of life for asby residents and the
surrounding towns by bringing outdoor
recreation via a recreational Rail Trail
Fort has been stonewalled by the state
for many years while attempting to
improve and enhance the RO rail Corridor
their request to utilize the rail bed
and explore new opportunities have
fallen on De years after years of
frustration I had an inspiration
literally from a dream the night before
the LSR filing period deadline ended
that I forced doot to do something via
railbed legislation so the bill before
you with the amendment I respectfully
ask that you replace the original bill
with the amendment and I ask you to OTP
it and I will take any questions going
okay thank you representative Smith
questions of Representative Smith from
the
committee questions of Representative
Smith all right seeing none thank you
very much for your testimony
Representative no problem thank you Mr
chairman uh next I will call upon Mr
Chris Elliot from Center oopy who
represents the fort and
oedc uh in favor of the
bill welcome to Public Works and
highways Mr ellot well thank you this is
my first experience down here so I'm I'm
learning something and uh it's great to
see all of you I've been um involved
with with Center oopy for almost 30
years and it's a great opportunity for
me to be here um again my name is Chris
Elliot I am a co-chair of the friends of
the asby rail trail and I'm also a
member of oedc stands for The asby
Economic Development Council and I'm
here to speak not only for myself but
also uh on behalf of both of the those
organizations and uh we both
organizations are in in strong support
of this recently proposed amendment that
would focus on the removal of the rails
and formalizing the corridor as a
recreational rail trail I am also Vice
chair of the friends of constitution
Park in OAB and also a member of the
outdoor spaces domain of the Mount
Washington age friendly Community
working on walkable
Trails uh I have dedicated considerable
time and effort to supporting our Loc
local community and to encouraging usage
of many outdoor recreation opportunities
for the area the economic social
physical and mental benefits of
recreational rail Trails have been well
documented in many studies in New
Hampshire and the rest of the country in
2021 uh the University of New Hampshire
extension in collaboration with the atin
Economic Development Council presented a
report strengthening connections this
was an extensive project that gathered
information over several years regarding
the possibility of using the underlied
underutilized existing rail Corridor
this Corridor meanders through uh
woodlands and oopy which is located at
the entrance of Mount Washington Valley
and is part of the Lakes Region we
encourage you to read this report if you
have the
time uh it is actually on the oop um
website under uh oedc resources since
the report has been presented oy has
already made improvements with sidewalks
lighting and signage small businesses
such as a coffee shop parir salon and
sewing alteration store in a town center
have also been open there are many
benefits uh uh of a rail trail in a
small town and I would just like to cite
some of them Trails boost spending at
local businesses that make communities
more attractive places to live Trails
influence business location and
relocation
decisions they reduce medical costs by
by encouraging exercise and other
healthy outdoor activities they
Revitalize depressed areas creating a
demand for space in what were once
vacant buildings Trails provide
transportation options and cut fuel
expenses they provide low or no cost
Recreation for families with low cost
relative to other recreational services
that could be provided by the government
they increase tax revenues in the
communities in which they are located
and these benefits represent a huge
economic return on the money invested
into their Trail projects I'm sure some
of you have rail trails in your own
constituencies and you know the value of
that additionally with the Cotton Valley
rail trail to the Southwest the Mount
Washington Valley W trail to the North
and the mountain division Trail and
fryberg Main to the Northeast having
this rail Corridor become a recreational
path would add to the network helping to
connect these communities along the way
it is important that this Corridor be
actively used some way so it can help
stimulate Economic Development and
Community Connections in our opinion the
best way to achieve these results would
be to convert this rail Corridor into a
recreational rail trail having this
vital piece of landscape sit dormant is
a waste of valuable asset to all the
communities that surround it it is time
to move forward with a positive and
impactful outcome I and the groups I
represent urge you to pass this Bill
thank you very much okay thank you Mr Al
questions Mr okay go ahead refes Mills
please thank you Mr chair I just have
one question um your WR your written
testimony was that given to us in this
original package uh what did we do have
it okay thank you yeah I'm taking it it
comes from some of the letters that I
wrote and I picked a few from here and
there that's all thank you very much the
one I did is probably not in your
package is the actual listing of the
benefits of the rail trail to a small
town I'm happy to leave a copy of that
please okay because I think you would
find that to be very useful question
okay all right okay mind okay you want
you have a question okay any other
questions uh from the committee of Mr
Elliot please yes represent jurus please
thank you thank you chairman U Mr Elliot
is it going to be the the charge of the
dot to remove the rails the the I I
think that's to be determined that's an
answer I can't I can't really give you I
don't know where we stand with that uh I
know our group uh will help out any way
they can uh obviously there's fund that
would need to occur to do all that and
and how we go about that uh this is
really the first opportunity we've ever
had actually to evil even come up and
talk about this topic so uh we're a new
group we're organized uh we have support
in fact one of the things that was
interesting when we had sort of an open
house in the town of asby uh we did a
survey afterwards and
76% of the the people who responded were
total favor of the rail trail and the
and the oedc has had Envision nights and
this idea of a rail trail recreational
Trail has been a very popular item but
the ca factors that you're talking about
I I just don't know the answer at at the
moment I'm sorry if I could follow up oh
yes please continue thank you Mr
chairman uh so it's the rails the ties
is there any other infrastructure in the
way well there are some uh there's
there's some prestel that cross some
some waterways that would have to be
analyzed and see if they're safe uh um
yeah the total
mileage well the total mileage is um if
you start from the center of OIP where
this project is and you go up to Route
41 it's about I think 9 10
miles it it starts in Center rby crosses
Route 16 and then goes up to towards
Madison uh along Route 41 there thank
you okay thank you uh further questions
on Mr Elliott for members of the
committee uh okay ref Farner please uh
in terms of recreational users do you
anticipate
um
uh you know Walkers bikes obviously but
uh is there a difference terms of
perception if we introduce snowmobiles
and then on top of snowmobiles perhaps
snowmobiles already use the trail other
ATVs uh snowmobiles already use the
trail ATVs do not and the whole question
about ATVs is an interesting one because
I think you discover throughout the
country and I think even in the state of
New Hampshire that most of your
recreational trails and uh bike trails
are non-motorized they would not allow
but they do allow the snowmobiles during
the winter
months okay any other questions
Representatives look like you had a okay
all right thank you uh further questions
of Mr Elliot for members of the
committee any further questions seen on
thank you very much for your testimony
Mr
Elliott okay next I will call upon Dr
Bob B bossy of the oopy chamber and
Friends of the con uh I'm sorry constant
Park I'm sorry if I'm mispronouncing
this in favor of the bill yeah it's it's
moose with a B Boose B okay Boose okay
I'm sorry didn't realize that thank you
when I testified in 1985 in Maine it was
b b okay whichever so it boost as far as
as long as it checked that the bounce Mr
chair um you know Chris and I have been
working together on on this project and
others and we thought in terms of the
testimony I'm not going to go over the
same ground that he he laid out there
but to bring to you um from my
perspective and my role as a director of
the Chamber of Commerce and oopy and and
a member of the FR Constitution Park
those two entities um are supporting
this effort because our vision as part
of our
um our mission is to enhance economic
and recreational opportunities they go
hand inand and we know that in that
Corridor in Roots 16 there's a golden
opportunity so we see a vision not only
for a business uh increase but also for
Community use I mean we see and I see
the kids walking down the trail and
running down the trail I just don't see
railroad tracks there so how do we get
there uh this bill is going to thanks to
to rep rep Smith trying to bring this to
a head and say what can we do or what
can't we do because we've been kind of
floundering uh and I'm not being
proagtive but just the way is and
somebody has to make a decision what is
the plan and can we fit in that plan I I
would implore you to open that plan that
we can work together collaboratively
with whether groups are using it we've
got to find some sense of we all can get
the benefit out of that so with with
that in mind I'll give you one other
plug um my wife who's the chair of the
of friends of uh Constitution Park
couldn't be here today because she's
writing a grant that do at the end of
the month and if I don't mention
something about that I won't be able to
go home so I just want to that she
supports that too and so does the
friends so thank you okay thank you Dr
boo questions of Dr Boo from members of
the committee any questions from do okay
yes go ahead please uh representative
yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um is any of this
active actively used isra
now I don't know if it's actively used
for Freight I
mean oh yeah go ahead please continue
represent do you know if any um State
money has been spent in the last 10
years to um maintain or upgrade those
tracks I have no
clue
is thank you okay okay thank you
represent kazinski any further questions
of Dr Boo for members of the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony Dr boo I will next call upon
Shelley Winters of New Hampshire dot who
has indicated no position on the bill
welcome back to Public Works and
highways Miss
Winters thank you so for the record my
name is Shy Winters I'm the director of
the division of Aeronautics Rail and
Transit at the Department of
Transportation here to provide some
technical testimony maybe clarify some
of the answers to questions that were
asked relative to State investment and
state usage and then answer any
questions you may have so um just by way
of a little bit of background the
department and the state purchas this
quarter and two phases purchased 8 miles
in Madison to the Albany colway Town
Line in 1995 using State funds which I
believe were capital state appropriated
Capital funds and then purchased 13
miles in Tamworth and oopy in 2001 those
were using Federal Highway
Transportation enhancement funds with
state capital match so those
Transportation enh enhancement funds on
those 13 miles would preclude motorized
vehicles such as ohvs but snowmobiles
would be allowed so in total the state
owns roughly 20 21 miles of state-owned
Conway Branch it's situated in between
New Hampshire North Coast the freight
provider to the South as an abutter and
Conway Scenic Railroad is the a butter
to the north which we all know runs
tourist Excursion
service um we own the corridor but since
2001 since our acquisition it has been
managed by the trails Bureau at
Department of Natural and cultural
resources through a Cooperative
agreement as the rail and ties are
largely in place dncr has availed that
only for winter recreational use as is
evidenced on their website due to safety
concerns with trips and falls over ties
and and rails so once they snow pack and
snow cover all the normal gamut of
recreational winter uses are availed by
dncr 2019 the department distributed a
request for interest on all uses of the
line rail or other commercial or
recreational um Trail uses we got two
responses at that time and they were
from a motor motorized railroad p putt
cars so to speak and then rail biking we
got no Trail interest at the time during
that RFI time so since that time again
covid and other things have taken
priority we've been working on an RFP
for on rail uses of the 21 miles I think
the subject Amendment before you is only
looking at a 15 mile segment of our 21
miles of ownership so our RFP that we're
working on and plan to release is for 21
miles of on rail uses and that allows us
to go through the Continuum of
Transportation uses that connect and we
understand there would need to be some
significant financial investment to
bring those up to certain on-rail uses
but we're going down that Continuum of
Transportation uses um at the end of the
day through our process we may get no
responses or no feasible responses that
could be financially solvent which may
lead us to the next um conversation
about recreational uses we've been
engaged with d NCR throughout the
process receiving their feedback on our
RFP and on our timeline I've talked to
several of the um the gentlemen who have
already testified about the ability
perhaps for two uses to coexist if rail
biking or other on-rail uses that are
low speed um were selected to bring
revenue and economy and tourism our
RightWay may still be able to
accommodate an on rail use and a trail
use we just don't know until we get to
the end of that process so um we're
planning to to forge ahead with that 21
Mile RFP for our whole ownership we have
been staff and resource constraint the
rail Bureau is a general funded Bureau
of the department we have one engineer
responsible for all railroad lines in
the state one railroad planner we have
about 500 miles between abandoned
corridors and active corridors that
we're responsible for um we've got a a
bureau administrator who's only 50%
oversight of rail that was vacant for 9
months that was my position and it will
become vacant again uh Friday so we've
had some constraints it's still
something we're working on and uh but
wanted to let you know about that as
well as we just hired a consultant and
we're doing an update to our 2012 State
rail plan and uh we'll be going through
that over the next year and a half and
part of that process we'll be looking at
all privately owned and publicly owned
State railroad quarters agnostic of
their current use and looking at it from
a network perspective trying to uh look
at into the future and look at the
long-term use and connectivity so we're
looking at a framework to try to
evaluate any um segments of railroad
quarters that are currently out of
service such as the Conway Branch so
there's a history to it there's a lot
going on we think we can work in
parallel with the amendment but we're
still planning at this point in time to
to continue um with our RFP and with
that I'm happy to answer any questions
you may have okay thank you Miss wers
questions on Miss wers from members of
the committee okay representative Newton
followed by representative fauler thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question uh very good testimony very
informative um I have a little concern
about the trestles can you tell me what
bodies of water they're over and do you
see the trestles as a big hurdle for
this to make them safe for people to go
over so I can provide a list out a I
don't know them all off the top of my
head we do have a inventory of all those
right now because dncr is the one who is
managing the recreational use it's um
depart Do's position that dncr evaluate
those prior to opening them up for the
season certainly depending on the type
of use that this line is ultimately used
for whether it's rail service rail
biking or a trail that would be a
Paramount safety concern and
consideration that what other entity is
going to be ultimately responsible for
constructing and maintaining would want
to do those evaluations to make sure
that it can handle the loads and is safe
for those um use type so we have not
done inspections as of late because we
do not as do use those right now thank
you okay thank you rep I'm fauler please
thank you I think you explained that
dncr manages the recreational Trails uh
can you describe what the relationship
between dncr and the municipalities
where current rail trails are and and
even with private uh volunteer groups
who help uh help maintain those
Trails sure I believe and uh Craig reny
from the trails bureau chief would
probably be able to uh more eloquently
state it but I I believe it's different
quarter to quarter based on whether
there's a year round use or it's a
winter recreational use only in some
instances they partner with the
communities through which the trails
they manage go through I know they
establish agreements with many of those
municipalities they have agreements with
snowmobile clubs and and other
recreational Trails clubs to assist them
with maintenance so there are some um
responsibilities incumbent upon through
those contracts I don't know uh in the
Conway area what they have for
formalized relationships I know if we
get calls about an issue on the Conway
branch in Winter use we do refer the
caller or we ourselves reach out to dncr
and they have a field staff person who's
responsible for that Conway
area okay thank you uh further questions
on Miss Winters from members of the
committee are there any further
questions okay thank you very much M oh
you do have
something goad Mr chairman thanks for
the question uh taking my question so on
this Branch you're exploring every
option the rail division is
exploring every option through that
segment through the RFP we're going to
be soliciting on rail uses only and then
see if those on rail uses if they're
viable do they also support um a trail
option within our right of way because
we a wi of right way through there but
okay thank Youk okay thank you again any
further questions yes go ahead referent
Boger
please I'm from the uh Lakes Region and
we have a trail we call it the wild
trail that goes alongside the railroad
tracks and a lot of places we're
required to put fence lines and stuff in
so that we can partner with it and the
question I have is in this situation
where it's
not an active rail line but you want to
keep the rails in place would the
similar situation be required to put a
fence line in between the non-rain used
railroad tracks in the trail beside it
if that's the one of the options that is
made I think until we know what the on
rail uses are and which ones if any are
viable that we would enter into a
contract that would go through Governor
Council it's hard to tell if if it were
certainly if it were a freight railroad
coming
through the offsets would be much more
stringent and how far off the center
line and the fening if through the RFP
process let's just say for conversation
sake it was a rail biking which we know
is a is very low speed and and low risk
it's likely that we may just require a
certain physical offset without having
to have fence between it it really
depends on if any on rail uses are
selected and what is selected what is
the speed and what is the potential for
that on rail use to come off the the
tracks and have any kind of interaction
with with the trail so um follow up okay
yeah follow up please continue represent
now the uh bridges that are transverse
into waterways and stuff um are they
able to to handle a train currently
so certainly they would all need to be
expected they'd all need to be inspected
again they'd all need to be um load
rated when the department acquired that
quarter I don't believe they we got a
full set of the load rating and the
bridge information so that is certainly
something that a respondent would need
to take into mind if they respond to the
on rail RFP so go out and and look at
that and figure that into their cost
calculations and we wouldn't sign off on
the operation of any on rail service
until uh the department was satisfied
that that was going to be done safely so
it would need to be done in the future
by an by an entity if they wanted to
start rail service further question
please continue now based on the the
bill with the amendment and stuff before
us um these same bridges are usually not
designed for foot
traffic but an on rail bike system would
would wouldn't hamper the bridge
use uh I don't I don't see it but so my
question would be is if it's allowed to
have foot traffic across these
Bridges who would be the plan or what is
the plan to pay for such changes to
these bridges that would have to take
place in order for foot traffic to
happen yeah pun intend but we'd have to
cross that bridge when we get there
again and until we know um where these
theoretical rail bikes would want to go
I think many of them may try to avoid
atg grade Crossings and as many bridges
as they can to minimize their their cost
certainly if we could have two uses
theoretical rail bike and a trail
coexist um we'd have to look at that
bridge and we'd have to look at the the
use um how many days a week and and when
the rail bikes would be used to see if
there could be a way that the trail
comes back onto that bridge and and
obviously Trail users would have to
yield to the through traffic or whether
or not the bridges themselves could have
let's call a a small Trail can levered
off the side of there or build a small
Bridge some of these are you know
streams and lower volume waterways but
again until we know what the uses are
and we know the speed and the frequency
it's it's hard to to come up with that I
will say overall um the department does
not directly through the Bureau of rail
and Transit fund any of the trail
construction it's usually incumbent upon
um the trail advocates so the
municipalities or dncr to um find Grant
funds and and local match funds to help
with the construction and the Perpetual
maintenance of those corridors okay
thank you further questions thank you
represent bogar further any oh yes
represent Adar please oh thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my
question I was wondering and I might
have been looking at all this paperwork
uh so hopefully haven't already answered
this question but uh relative to your
your saying you don't have an RFP out
you there other studies or whatever that
are being done um and also knowing that
some of the trails I've been on is that
there is just the rail bed there's just
the rails and there's not like roads
next to them some have a service road
some don't but um when would you know
from this review that's being done if in
fact it would be acceptable to take
right at this time to take out the the
rails and the
ties so I and it's a lot of predicated
thank you for your question R Edgar I
think it's predicated on when we put the
RFP out um one of the things that we
think is very important for any
potential respondent because this has
been dormant or just winter use for some
time is letting the snow melt and
letting potential respondents see the
condition so they can look at the
bridges they can look at the drainage
and they can try to
um better estimate what their
construction their all-in cost would be
so I think we're hoping we've got it
pretty much ready ready to go out but we
need to hold it to allow a twoe period
so that respondents can go look at the
quarter to come up with their financial
plan and then submit to us so I'm
thinking sometime by the end of this
state fiscal year the department could
be through the process where we've
received um proposals and Whitted it
down to whether you know whether there's
any Financial viability and return on
investment for the state so that's why I
I kind of said I think in tandem these
could work knowing the timing of when
this may actually um be in place we as
the department may be better able to
come to the table with the results of
our RFP or at least the early results
that let us start the discussion of
whether there's a coexistent of multiple
uses or whether we have no viable uses
and we now just start talking um pure
recreational and and Trail based use
thank you okay thank you further
questions of Miss Winters from members
of the committee further questions I see
none thank you very much for answering
all our questions Miss
Winters
okay I will next call upon
representative Mark mccon in favor of
the
Bill thank you Mr chairman esteem
members of the committee um I'm here in
in support of um of Representative
Smith's
um
Amendment um and I'm also a
co-sponsor um I would like
to give a little more background of
where we are with this the the uh Conway
branch of the rail which is inactive is
at least a 20 mile length all this all
this that that we're proposing to use
here is a 9 to a 10 Mile Stretch that
stretch starts at an old Freight station
in
oy um and runs to the
reconstructed uh train station at Silver
Lake in Madison it's the only section
that we're we're looking to deal with uh
there there was a there still is a train
station in Tam in U in West oopy and
this is part of the famous ski train
that ran a number of years and then
there was some little bit of freight
activity and then there's been nothing
from that point on I uh resided and
raised my family in the town of oy I
should back up I represent the good
people of uh District 8 in Carrol county
oopy is not one of my uh my towns I did
represent him early on in
2000s uh I raised my family there my
heart is in that
town
the so we're only talking about a 10
Mile Stretch when the bill first came
out and it went to uh OS to look at it
it came back with a recommendation of a
$200,000 master
plan I know there are some members of
this committee don't like to see numbers
like that in spent and it's a hindrance
in the process this is real simple the
town of oopy has been asking for five
years or more to let the citizens walk
on this section of rail and the
department has said no you cannot we we
will not permit that we will not avoid
liability or provide liability for that
section but don't worry folks we've got
an RFP coming out and that RFP has been
in the wind for over five years and that
RFP is still being talked about
today the we removed or Mr Smith
removed um the original Bill and brought
it back to talking about uh instead of a
master
plan um a a group a Planning Group
Department of
Transportation of rail the Bureau of
trails uh will work together with
executive counselor district one members
of the House Public Works Senate Capital
Selectmen representatives of the
Northeast uh New Hampshire North Coast
railroad to formulate a plan for the
Public's best use of this section of
rail the rail this the rail would
explore the costs and income we will
look at what it costs to remove the
rails and take this down to a flat
surface there is no money being asked
from the state of New Hampshire from
this purpose there is no money being
requested from the rails division it's
just part of the study that what would
it take to get this down to a flat
surface
from my conversations with the rail
Division and and many others that the
the gauge of um or weight of this rail
that's sitting there right now is not
adequate enough even to carry Freight
now there's no possibility that rail
could ever come through excuse me
passenger traffic could ever come
through here because again of the of the
degraded rail so whatever happens in the
future
and this group knows full well as I know
full well if 20 years from now that um
rail makes sense to come through there
this trail goes away there'll be no
commitment for the railroad to build a
new Trail alongside it I don't think
we're going to see this in my lifespan
that that ever happens so why not let
the residents use that section of rail
um for whatever purpose it might be and
they'll be in full conversation with the
rail division the most active use of
this property right now is snowmobiling
Corridor 19 and it is a tremendous Boom
for business owners on or anywhere
near when there's plenty of snow and I
haven't seen that probably in 10 or 15
years and it's stacked up over the rails
it's easy to groom and there's not an
issue we tend not to see snow now until
February and by March things cool off or
excuse me warm up and it's gone again so
whatever limited time we had for
snowmobiles is greatly hampered because
as soon as you get your your I'm not a
snowmobile but you get your Runners down
into that and especially at the
intersections and The Crossings uh it
becomes extremely hazardous so I believe
there there is a letter in your packet
that talks about the rail division uh
with great interest to wanting wanting
to see this solution to
happen um there is no continuous the
when you leave molten bille Road in
moltonville Road in
Centos the the the rail is paved over
there's no way to cross from one side to
the other when they get down to Route 16
it's the same thing again the rail is
covered by there and when you get to 41
why do we choose that section and only
that section ahead of CER oopy the uh
and I apologize for not saying the right
name of the group out of wolfboro the
putt putt group that travels and they
have a successful Club they tend to only
ride down to CER oopy we don't want to
infringe with with their what they're
doing it's very limited that they will
ever cross over and go to the next
section the U there's a gentleman I
apologize for not knowing Hank's last
name um he had he tried to get an RFP
executive counselor Kenny which which is
why he's on this tried to get the
division to give them at least a
one-year trial he wanted to go from
where the pavement is in Silver Lake in
front of the um train station and he
wanted to go North to where um to where
the the rail is blocked now in
Madison and for well over a year whether
he did it correct or
incorrect an RFP couldn't be brought
forward
and or a decision by the department that
would allow him to run taking full
responsibility for that
liability Freight moves
slow the people of oy have no reason to
have to wait for this repeatedly I I
hear the story we've heard it today I
don't have enough
people uh we're going to get to it I
think this is a nice
solution uh no cost
we pull this group together and we we
explore all of those items the map for
this 10 m section is shown here and I
have a response to a few things
represent B ask for this an active Trail
it is not uh kazinski represent kazinski
had talked about how much money has been
spent on um on this section of the rail
the the my the best of my understanding
the only the only division that spent
money here is the trails
Bureau uh Trails Bureau thank you sir um
on their money for maintaining for the
snowmobiles and the put putt group I
will say has been a active participant
in providing u u transportation for that
for representative Newton the Trussel
that are there they they uh have been
upgraded and U for the purpose of
snowmobile travel over them and the the
two that I can think of the most have
wooden railings provided on the side if
it turned out the best use after this
working group were to come was Rails to
Trails I will not support the state
paying for that that'll be a private
fundraising Venture and whatever they
would need to make it safe for that for
that purpose to happen uh they will be
responsible for
that uh I finish up on on the U the
bikee rail section Hank Hank's purpose
was not to go
forward um to the section of of rail
that we're talking about it's a gorgeous
walk it's in the woods it's along
Wetlands uh there's not much chance at
all of veering off very few places to
put a side by-side Trail um the the
choice is to be as inclusive as possible
and unlike the representatives rail in
Trail hugely successful program in lonia
connecting with other Trails Tilton and
everywhere else there is no active rail
here and there won't be a need for
someone to pay for uh to pay for fencing
there I would be um I would be happy to
take any questions okay thank you
representative mononi questions of
Representative mcon for members
representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for appearing uh
is it your vision that the state would
continue to own the ra the uh rway yes
they
will and and if if I could and only if
rail were to return does the does the
rail bed then go back for a rail
purpose all right thank you further
representative fauler
please do we know whether the uh the
rail and less likely the ties have
salvage value which might decrease the
cost of uh removing
them thank thank you representative and
I and I appreciate the uh the question
uh part of part of the amendment talks
about explore funding Any Trail
improvements through private donations
grants or the sale of the existing steel
rails um I believe there'll be someone
speaking after we're of the opinion that
of course there is a value for that um
we're of the opinion that not every tie
has to be removed to get to that level
space because there's quite a few places
here that the senders are gone and we're
down to gr to grade already but yes it
is a
consideration thank you uh
representative Newton Police Follow by
RM jurors thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question um I've
got a I'm
wondering and you're from that area and
I'm just trying to figure out how to
phrase it best is it better to have a
trail system through there where people
can go through and kind of Steward it
and keep an eye on what's going on
or is it better to leave the train rails
vacant and will that lead to
deterioration and people going in and
dumping things in those areas is it just
would seem to me that it's more
beneficial to have a trail through that
system am I correct with that I I would
agree with the representative's position
thank you thank you represent jurist
please thank you Mr chairman the
representative has the group come up
with an estimate of what it would take
to remove the rails in the time
and any other environmental
uh uh mitigation that could be possible
thank you thank you for the question um
the uh working group uh excuse me I'm
not the the group um that spoke earlier
has not come to that has done that
exploration I know there has been
conversation with the Rails to Trails
group National Group on on estimated
cost but the problem is it's it's hard
to generate that interest to come up
with those numbers if you if you don't
know if you're going to get the right to
use it and the rails division piece has
been or what they've been saying is we
need to consider everything and anything
and
um so that has not been done but that
that will be after the after this
working group is formed and reports by
the end of next year uh then it will be
the responsibility of that group that
wants to come forward thank you okay
thank you further questions of
representative makoni from members of
the committee all right yes
representative mils yes just one uh
thank you Mr chair and question for Mr
chair I understand your your group is
just mainly interested in this 10
certain mile area would it would they be
interested or would it be any
feasibility to it for them to be
involved in this entire RFP project or
would there be no interest in that for
your group thank you for the question um
I have I have always found that it's
better to start with small bites and you
know get something working and then move
from there the conversation gets very
complicated when you take this all the
way to Conway because there's a diverse
a different group of uh people and
business owners and so forth and to date
we've heard that no one's had any
responses so I would think if this
becomes a success uccessful model my
hope is that it can grow further and I
believe one of the gentleman talked
about possibly even being a connection
on the Conway fryberg Loop in someday
future thank you thank you thank you ref
Mills further questions yes ref B
please thank you for the question
um the one thought is everybody keeps
thinking about removing the rails and
everything and
which is going to create with especially
with the Creo tides and stuff like that
it's going to create other issues has
there been any thoughts of just doing a
overlay leaving the tracks and stuff in
place and and overlaying on top of them
and that way if something happens down
the road if it needs to be reactivated
just the overlay is done and you still
got your track bed thank you thank you
for the question um I have been involved
in trails I've I have
uh I have started the asby lake uh bike
path and and many other ventures in my
work through Lakes Region Planning
Commission for nearly 30 years the what
I have seen out there when they have
filled between the rail beds whether it
be Cinders or some other surface it
becomes a very big maintenance item and
who's who's going to take care of that
these rails have no use going
forward um are there cre assault in
these but I I I'm hearing that if they
were to take up the roaded and put new
rails in in that 10 Mile section that
would be in excess of $20
million the um I believe North Coast
will talk about their sections that
they're going to rehab um and they're
finding that U taking the steel away
leaving what has to be there um you know
and will you know how much of that will
that will be a cost number they'll look
at as much as I love Rail and I do love
Freight rail I don't I don't see that
this is coming
back in our
lifetime thank you ref Bogart okay any
other questions of Representative
mononi all right seeing none thank you
very much representative mcon I will now
call upon Mr David Camp Bill supporting
the bill as amended I believe and I'm
sorry I may miss the Northeast Coastal
Railroad and uh I want welcome
back welcome back uh Mr Campbell who's a
former representative including chair
and vice chair of the of the committee
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee always nice to be back in
public works I understand you would know
the name if the calendars didn't get
flooded I understand yeah I I I I did
yeah and I was one of the ones that got
my calendar before the that's all right
so uh I appeared before you today uh in
favor of the the amended the amendment
um New Hampshire North Coast is included
in it we appreciate that being in the
loop I mean we are the connecting
railroad uh and we like to know what's
going on uh you know to to our immediate
north um I also have the ability right
now because we are in the middle of some
Rehabilitation some new rail to give you
realtime numbers some real numbers not
what estimates are but we've got numbers
for taking a piece of old spur which is
very similar to this taking the old
track being a spur and we can
extrapolate how much it would cost to
take the 70 pound rail that's to the
north and put new ties and new Ballance
to make it a working
railroad um I want you hear people talk
about pounds rail 70 pound rail 85 pound
rail 110 pound rail 136 pound rail which
is like the big
stuff that that is a every three feet of
rail that's that's how many pounds a
pounds of rail is in three feet so it's
if it's if it's a 75 PB rail three feet
of that rail will weigh 75 PBS if it's
eight if it's 115 pound 3 feet of that
rail Will C that's how they gauge it if
course you put them next to each other
you'll see their different sizes um
so just looking at some of these numbers
and it's why I'm happy to share these
with the working committee because I
think it'll be helpful but here's some
of the things I like to share with you
today um if you just wanted to make that
at a working railroad I mean first off
we understand the state law we
appreciate and want the state law all
quarters have to be if rail comes back
it becomes a rail quarter and that's why
we
support know this amendment however
let's temper that with realism uh the
realistic part is I don't believe the
costs are such that it'll never be
afraid railroad just to bring it back up
to 70 pound which couldn't handle
today's 100 ton per car fr
would cost $1.6 million a mile just to
do the tracks ballast
ties um that doesn't
include uh
bridges trestles yeah I mean culverts
underneath the rail for drainage uh
grade Crossings and signalization that's
going to boost that by a minimum of 25%
as much as almost doubling it but say
1.6 million that's go turns into two
conservatively and that's based on our
low bid this year in
2024 um that's 20 $24 going forward
inflation is going to kick that and our
low bid by the way that that was our low
bid we had bids that were double that so
it's very volatile it's very expensive
so it is not an exaggeration I think
it's conservative to say it would be a
minimum of you know to do 10 miles would
be $20 million a bare minimum and then
what are you left with 70 pound rail
which you really can't use you want to
upgrade to something that's useful like
115 pound probably cost you maybe 25 to
million again this is just wild because
you don't know how bad the bridges are
the trestles are the culverts are you
just have no idea but these are minimum
I think uh costs now you look at that
what economic engine is going to drive
that where is there going to be enough
volume of freight to justify that it it
isn't going to happen and not just in
our lifetime in anybody's lifetime
because there there'll be some other
need in some other urban area that has
that draws on these funds it's just very
very difficult so and and we fight it on
our little railroad where we go where we
do have active customers
so I think one other thing I can share
with you is the cost of taking out oh or
the salvage value if you wanted to get
rid of the rail and pull it out to make
a level surface there is salvage value
there but again that market is all over
the place it was really high during
covid now it's down about 150 a ton I
think for for Salvage steel um I think
there may be a better value in relay
rail you know some small railroads
Excursion railroads want the SE go slow
like the 70 lb relay maybe the state
could barter that you know the state
could could either Salvage or so but
there's some money that can come back in
to pay for this the other thing is
removing the the ties as representative
mcon said you wouldn't want to remove
all the ties just the ones that were
trip hazards and the other ones you keep
right in place because believe you take
it out of the ground they do have Creos
Sal they have to be disposed of our cost
to take a disposed tie out of the rail
right now old ties is
$34 so it's $34 a tie and that's again
20 $24 real bid low bid $34 a tie
so if you got 10,000 ties do the math
you know it's a lot of money 340,000
right
so these are all considerations um that
I would be happy to share the numbers
because we're right in the middle of it
where we've got the bids in contractors
been contracts have been awarded and
we're doing construction this summer so
we can help this working committee with
some numbers but there may be a way to
do it the the steel is the most is where
there's value and the ties
obviously the less you take out the
better because of the great cost of
disposing of them I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you Mr Campbell
questions of Mr Campell members of the
committee any questions seeing none
thank you very much Mr Campbell
appreciate it I will now call upon Mr
Daniel I believe day from Durham New
Hampshire in opposition to the bill and
I just want to say we have a hearing
coming up in a few minutes so if we
could try to keep Our Testimony to what
you wrote if not a little shorter and
just keep that in mind because we have
another hearing scheduled for and I
don't want to go over too much thank you
Mr day yeah know I understand I'll keep
this brief and yes my name is Daniel day
um last name spelled DIY I am from
Durham and I am the Visionary of a
startup company that actually has an
immediate on rail commercial interest in
a portion of the Conway branch and I am
also aware of at least two other people
who have expressed commercial interest
in the line as well so we all know that
there is actual commercial potential for
at least a portion of this line um the
exact portion is yet to be determined I
have read previous reports of the line
and believe my plan would go well within
the parameters of what is best for the
region and I am working with a team of
experts and Industry professionals with
to and have been in talks with the
do as well as um a neighboring property
and all the talks have been very
positive and I am confident that my
proposal would be an economic
development driver to the area an
exciting Revenue opportunity for the
state and just an overall great
opportunity for the people of New
Hampshire so I believe we should keep
our options open with the RFP and and
give people a chance to submit their
proposals okay thank you questions of
the gentleman from members of the
committee question the gentleman okay
seeing none it'd be more than happy to
to submit if you have any other through
the email to the committee if you have
further questions or comments thank you
very much okay thank you very much for
your testimony I will now call upon Mr
Mike Lacy of Conway New Hampshire
representing the I believe it's
csrr in support of the bill
okay welcome to Public Works and
highways Mr Lacy okay there's two of you
yeah there's there's two of us uh so
okay could you the only thing is could
the other one s out a pink card too
please that's our rules absolutely okay
all right and you're Mr Lacy right no
actually this is Mike okay so uh I I
asked Mike to go ahead and drive down
here because I actually flew from a
meeting in North Carolina this morning
to attend this okay and your name sir
David and I'm the owner of the Conway
Scenic okay and I appreciate you filling
a pink card afterwards so absolutely
well so um I guess I I just wanted to uh
express my interest in always having the
ability to bring new equipment into the
Conway cic Railroad and currently we
have a connection to the north very long
and what's problematic with that
connection is it's seasonal so every
time the snow comes there's snow slides
there all kinds of diff difficulties so
it's not really a practical system to
get new equipment to the railroad now we
purchased Conway Scenic five years ago
we've effectively doubled the size of
the company so there's tremendous
economic benefit to our railroad right
now in the last five years it we've
contributed approximately $154 million
to the state economy so lots of good
stuff so my primary thing is we'd like
to go ahead and have a reliable con
connection if the North Coast Road want
to work with us perhaps that's an
opportunity going south of here um when
you look at these Rail lines one thing I
would suggest is you know the department
of rail Transit has really done a lot of
work to go ahead and try to develop what
we should do with these Rail lines for
the future it's not just about today
it's the future I would definitely
suggest that we go through that process
see what the RFP turns up because maybe
it's something that Conway Scenic works
with the North Coast and you have an
opportunity to go ahead and do something
else so from that standpoint I really
appreciate your time today and uh and
thank you okay thank you Mr s uh Mr Lacy
you all set you don't have anything okay
good and questions of Mr s or Mr Lacy
from members of the
committee are there any questions yes
represent bogert please so you
support what they're trying to do or do
you support what they're trying to do
with the caveat of the continuance of
the RFP uh with the caveat of the RFP
because I I think it's very important to
go and fulfill and go through that
process because it was a well thought
out process and that can root out and
quantify you know what reality is here
because uh just us sitting here it's not
something that you know we're painting
accurate picture so I think that we had
to go through that
process thank you a representative
jurist please follow by represent you Mr
chairman Mr s i when you talk about
making a connection you mean making a
connection on the on the Conway Scenic
in in every direction including this
this possible right away or or uh did I
misunderstand well current so current
yes what I'm trying to say here is that
currently the
the dot is studying the different Rail
lines in the state and they're trying to
see what the best moves going forward
are if you look at uh a connection
providing a connection to the outside
world for Conway Scenic which is really
important for future growth of that
company of our company uh South seems to
be a very reasonable way of doing it so
until we bet this process out we can't
really decide what to do thank you
you're welcome thank you uh represent
Newton please thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question so if you
had a chance to review the amendment and
would you say that this would be helpful
in what you're trying to do or would it
be restrictive in what you're trying to
do so unfortunately we haven't had a
chance to review the amendment we were
just invited to this meeting without
benefit of that
so
okay thank you ref further questions of
Mr swerk and Mr Lacy from members of the
committee further questions I seeing
none another pink card oh I'm sorry from
the other hearing okay so any anybody
else want to say anything for or against
this bill okay good uh represent could
you please pass me up the blue sheet so
I need to read who signed
in
okay yeah yeah and just make sure you
fill out a pink card please Mr s
got okay good thank you Mr s all right
okay and the blue
sheet
okay all
right and Mr chairman uh yes while we're
waiting um the packet that we received
can it contained a lot of correspondents
from various businesses in support of
the bill and I'm hoping that they'll be
incorporated into the public record yeah
I think it has to be anyway it all goes
okay thank you very much
okay okay thank
you that's okay so no one signed in okay
great okay thank you very much I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
1468 thank you
and we will get started with our next
Hearing in a minute or
two thank
you
oh
yeah we're still
making
thank you
John all right so we are
at so if there's anyone that wishes to
testify on House Bill 1510 just please
fill out a pink card and uh pass that
along representative Newman on on my
left and we
will include
you and we are pretty darn close to our
appointed time uh before I open up the
hearing I would just like to uh make an
apology to the sponsor and to the people
coming uh they'll be testifying that um
with our confusion last week or the week
before about taking this bill and I can
assure you you have the full attention
of our com of our committee now at this
time with that I will open up the 210
hearing at
27 and the house bill 1510 establishing
a commission to identify barriers to and
solutions for electric vehicles sales
and use and I believe I have the prime
sponsor uh representative Rebecca
McWilliams every now and then I get one
and with that would you please present
your
uh House Bill thank you very much chair
members of the committee it's a pleasure
to be here for the record my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I'm
from South conquered you're sitting in
one of my districts it's a pleasure to
host you um and so I'm I'm here to talk
a little bit about EVS I've passed out
both an amendment to the bill that I'm
presenting as well as an article that
some of you already saw the last time I
was here for very brief appearance um
and I know that this committee has heard
some other bills about EVs and the
status of EVS so I don't want to spend a
ton of time talking about history or
technology or anything like that happy
to have a sidebar with individuals about
those topics because I'm very passionate
about them uh but big picture I think
it's uh fair to say that EVS are
definitely a hot topic right now in uh
political circles and the legislature uh
and therefore I think it is appropriate
for us to take some time and actually
look into where are we and what should
we be doing in terms of public health
safety and Welfare um and as well as
industry adoption and changes in
transportation um that being said there
is a sister bill I would describe it as
a sister bill um in the Senate right now
uh how Senate Bill 430 um which is
similar but not quite the same um the
title of that bill is a council to study
the impacts of electric vehicles
e-mobility devices and Associated
lithium ion batteries on first responder
response the environment building and
fire codes life safety and property
protection all things that we're charged
with taking care of as elected
representatives we care about the health
and safety of our constituents um so
this bill that I've presenting on the
house side um is similar in that uh the
the charge of this goal is to identify
barriers and solutions to Electric
Vehicle sales and use and I would
certainly say use is sort of a big
picture which includes First Responders
the environment building and fire codes
um so I think there's probably a way for
us to figure this out and I imagine that
there may be a committee of conference
to reconcile the goals of both of these
two bills um that being said uh between
the last time I was here at this
committee and uh today I had a great
conversation with the folks at the
office of legislative services
in regards to how commissions must be
structured um and I didn't realize until
I sent out this amendment that we needed
to have one more elected official than
we do members of the public on a
commission so the amendment that I
passed out today includes seven elected
officials and six of the other people
who are not electeds to meet our
criteria that you need to have one more
legislator on the commission um and uh
and so that that was sort of a scrier
error on my part I apologize but also I
hope this makes it right in terms of the
makeup of the commission um I think
you've probably already heard a lot in
the news and possibly even another
testimony on this committee about um
safety and concerns with ev's uh
spontaneously combusting right we've
we've certainly heard some of this on
the news about um certain EVS not being
safe for public use or at least having
some concerns about that as well as
charger fires um wherever the Chargers
are located um poor installation or
faulty uh mechanics and I do think that
that's something that as a commission we
should be looking into because this has
to do with Public Safety and the health
of our constituents um big picture I
know that the automotive Dealers
Association in New Hampshire has been uh
interested in figuring out what what
needs to happen for the market to shift
in New Hampshire um I know that in
states around New Hampshire there have
been some programs for cash on the hoods
or some kind kind of rebate program for
purchasing EVS as the market shifts New
Hampshire has not adopted such a program
but it be could be something to look
into and really it's at the discretion
of this commission to decide how things
are handled and what the recommendations
are in the report to come um so for all
of the reasons that I've outlined this
is really a goal to get something
together to talk about it and see what
we can do as a
legislature um also I do want to note
that there was um in
2018 this is a very thick report so I've
emailed it to everyone instead of
printing it and send and giving it to
you on paper copy um but in 2018 there
was a study
commission um under Senate Bill
517 chapter 1541 laws of
2018 it was a electric vehicle charging
stations infrastructure commission which
also looked at some of the things that
we're now seeing becoming more
mainstream with EVs and so this would be
a follow-up commission to look at again
some of the health and safety concerns
that came out of the report I've emailed
it to everyone if you want to spend some
time reading it at another date so with
that I'm happy to take
questions uh questions for for the
representative yes I'm sorry uh
representative fauler please thank you
for the question um first uh I'm a EV
owner just to point of view learned a
lot about them the course of buying them
it seems like we have a lot of
experience and a lot of knowledge
especially if we go to other states
other countries in terms of how how to
deal with these somebody's El figured
out this problem how do we keep this
commission from basically kind of
falling into a debate on climate change
or other sort of
political U Hot Topic items instead of
and and and perhaps make it focus on
what it is that we need to do to solve
whatever problems we
identify uh is this
a I'm just concerned that the subject
matter is too wide open and we'll kind
of fall into General things as there
language that could could make that more
focused um thank you very much for the
question uh I would say that uh the
charge is specific on this bill and
again this may be reconciled with the
Senate bill but the charge is specific
on this bill to study identify barriers
to and solutions for electric vehicle
sales and use so if there's a way to
sort of tailor that to be a little bit
more specific to the economics of said
topic um nowhere in this does it say
climate change and I know those can be
very incendiary terms so this is really
more about a changing Market um and what
we are doing in response to a changing
Market as opposed to things that can be
hot topics I would say that uh because
we have seven elected officials on the
commission the select the selection of
those seven elected officials makes a
big deal about what's discussed at each
of their meetings obviously and so um
I'm not responsible for appointing those
seven people but if there are
recommendations for those seven people
who could stay away from hot button
topic discussions that's probably a path
towards finding some answers and so I
would leave that to the speaker and the
minority leader if this bill moves
forward because we really do want to get
some good
answers thank you further questions
representative mcams uh representative
cludia hey thank you representative MC
Williams I noticed on Roman numeral five
of the bill it says the commission shall
report its findings and any
recommendations for proposed legislation
to the Speaker of the House of
Representatives the president of the
Senate and the house clerk Senate clerk
governor and State library on or before
December 31st of 2026 I was just curious
why you pick that particular date which
is a little far out you know for some
people uh sure I think that
um it's the sort of topic that deserves
good uh significant amount of study um
and imagining that probably there won't
be much work performed this year
2024 so it would really be a 20 25 and
2026 duration that that was my intent
I'm open to an amendment on that date
okay thank you representative mck
Williams further questions for the
representative I have a question for you
representative um thank you for this
um I've had the pleasure of as several
of the members of this committee have
had the pleasure of being on another
commission and finding as you just said
time in the first year runs out very
very quickly so you need to be out at
least two or three
years I do could you tell me I know it
will be the commission's job but can you
identify a few barriers as you see them
right now in this
process uh sure this is highly technical
uh but keep it simple for Mark okay
technical all right um so at the federal
level um we have an air emissions
standard that has been adopted by most
of the states in the Northeast New
Hampshire has not adopted that air
emission standard uh the manufacturers
of vehicles the big ones at least but
pretty much every manufacturer 4gm Etc
um have prioritized delivering EVS to
dealers in States who have adopted the
federal air emission standard which
means that when they're loading up their
18wheeler and they're putting all the
EVS on there to deliver them to deal
dealers in different states New
Hampshire is dead last in the Northeast
for priority of delivery of EVS because
we have not adopted the air Mission
standard
okay thank you for that sure uh any
other further questions at this
point thank you for your testimony
you'll have an opportunity at the end if
there's something else you'd like to say
I'd like to move to our
second uh second
speaker uh Sean Tumi uh State Fire
Marshall welcome sir welcome to public
works good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
having me today uh representative MC
Williams at a a great job doing an intro
and I think it sounds like you've had a
fair amount of information on this so
far so I did send some written testimony
hopefully I made it through the portal I
don't know we made it there but um the
in regards to sen Bill uh 4:30 uh the
department of safety has kind of helped
initiate that bill over the summer uh
the Fire Marshal's Office brought a
group together stakeholders um to try to
start talking about this mostly from the
public safety perspective police and
fire response um it included a lot of
people it included the Fire Marshal's
Office the New Hampshire Fire Chiefs New
Hampshire police Chiefs uh Department of
Transportation d uh DMV DS uh auto
dealers tow Association and there's
probably up to 20 people that we've been
meeting we've had three meetings so far
and the thought we had is just really to
take a moment to take some time and
understand the issue and put some
thought into it rather than just the
shotgun approach that we've seen so far
I think this session where uh outright
bans and
um uh prohibit proh prohibiting them
from parking garages for instance and
things like that so our goal um that
we've been working on in the fire
Marshall's office is really to try to
gather data um there's about 400 car
fires uh reported in the state a year
and um we think only about two of those
fires were electric vehicle fires um The
Challenge from the fire service
perspective is when when a electric
vehicle fire happens they're more severe
and the tactics to put them out is much
different much more demanding on
resources especially from the water spy
perspective um versus an internal
combustion uh vehicle so uh we we just
the the lithium ion batteries in general
they they they're subject to Thermal
runaway and they're a little bit less
predictable so we want time to kind of
look at what the national work's going
on there's a ton of national work going
on uh from the code perspective um the
International Code Council has stood up
an ad hoc committee to look at batteries
um NFPA which is the National Fire
Protection Association uh has a A
Research Foundation they stood up a
group to look at batteries and car
related fires and then UL Underwriters
lab uh their Fire Safety Research
Institute set up a um a program to look
at car fires they they're going to go so
far as to look at the differences a lot
of the studies that we saw from cars are
from vehicles in the 70s and 80s and as
we know vehicles have a lot more
Plastics in them now so you know really
taking a hard look at what's the
difference between the cars that we know
of the 70s and 80s which more more steel
and steel and you know metal Parts
versus what the Plastics and then
looking at the EV stuff so I think in
general uh the department of safety and
and the fire marshal office supports
bringing a group of stakeholders
together to really take a look at this
look at the national information that's
available look at the national studies
that are happening really take a look at
what's happening in our state from a um
from a data perspective and make good
decisions um rather than just blanketly
you know uh getting into situations
where we're prohibiting outrate
prohibiting the vehicles or things like
that without really a thoughtful process
so um again we're supportive of that um
you you know and happy to answer any
questions thank you thank you any
questions for the fire marshal yes
rebner I really want to commend that uh
that point of view I think that that's
very helpful and I'm wondering if there
any parallels I know at one
time fire departments weren't U equipped
to deal with with gasoline powered
vehicles and over the last 100 years or
so we've developed equipment are there
any parallels that you see between the
adoption of Motor Vehicles 100 years 125
years ago versus where we're facing it
now and and how was how different fire
departments responded to that yeah thank
you I I I think that in general what
we've said is that technology has
outpaced us in a lot of these areas and
it's just taking some time to come up so
there's there's different things that
are coming out there's blankets to put
over vehic electric vehicles which
probably could translate to a regular
vehicle as well but um there's there's
special nozzles to try to get up under
the batteries so right now everyone's
just trying to learn at this point Point
um so I I think we're we're really in
that learning phase but because of the
intensity of it and the time it takes to
put the fires out everything's kind of
in a sort of a you know a little bit of
a pause and it's a concern right if we
shut down for here at home shut down 93
on a Friday afternoon in the summer or
ski season in the winter because we're
we're three four hours trying to put
this vehicle fire out um it's very
different than conquer fire going out
and putting a car fire out in a few
minutes uh right now so um I think it's
going to take a little bit time to
evolve um there's there's a little bit
of a growing mindset of that vehicle
fire say go back to the 93 example is
just knock it down get it on a recer and
get it off the highway and then get it
to a safe spot and probably let it burn
but then you know it gets into some of
the climate decisions of is it what's
better is the water runoff going to be
an issue when we put thousands of
gallons of water on it or is just to let
it burn and what's the air quality issue
so I think some of that's just grappling
um I think the biggest thing from the
fire safety perspective I hear other
than the time and the the resources it
takes is the when you put it in a you
know in a parking garage that has an
apartment building above it um and you
know that where go back to it takes a
few minutes to put a regular internal
combustion engine vehicle out where this
go back to you know potentially IA put
an EV fire out is the structural
protection between the residential and
the commercial space okay um is the
sprinkler system capable of doing it
there's some research now saying if you
bump the design capacity of the of the
sprinkler system for that residential up
one category above what it is now that's
going to help protect the structure and
help protect the cars around it so I
really think we're in a research mode um
you know but I I think that uh you know
I go back to let's focus on the study
and not just say no right um it's going
to take a little bit of time to figure
out that uh transition from horse and
buggy to internal combustion and now to
these EVS but uh they're making fire
engines that are EVS right now so I mean
it's you know uh concern we heard
recently is that you know that the
propane delivery trucks for our homes if
we have Propane fuel they're making
those EVs and the people are kind of
very concerned about that you know if
you put a propane tank sitting above a
some electric batteries well there's got
to if they're making them there's got to
be some protection we got we got to
figure this out so we just need some
time thank you represent ffi
please yes just pull that your mic a
little closer to you
sir there hello yeah
on TV about three weeks ago there was
some
agency I don't remember the name they
said it takes 3600 gallons of water to
put out a fire on an
EV have you heard anything about that
there's all over the place there's that
amount to tens of thousands of gallons
of water um you know so it is it's all
over the place there's stories of people
getting trapped in the back seats of EVs
and dying and but we we can't find that
data and that that's I think my biggest
concern is that if we're going to make
decisions on on these things we need to
have good factual data that can be
verified um and not just make sort of
knee-jerk reactions to to uh to rules
and regulations around on stuff thank
you further yes representative
Boger uh thank you for taking my
question
um in your statement you mentioned that
when you put an EV in a parking garage
that has
residential uh housing above it that you
might have to add to the cost of the
construction of this units in order to
incorporate the use of EV EVs and I'm
just curious in a climate of where we're
trying to lower the price of housing but
yet to accommodate an electric vehicle
we
find everywhere we turn we're increasing
the price of everything else around it
in order to accommodate an EV am am I
going down the wrong track here or I I I
think that's something we're trying to
look at and I think the other thing is
you know go back to that UL study that I
mentioned they're they're looking at did
was there a change from metal components
to plastic components and like so what's
different what's the differential
between those two so I don't
personally I want to wait for the the
studies to come out before I make that
hard and fast decision um but um we know
that a metal all metal vehicle is very
different than a plastic vehicle and we
know it's different if a battery get if
if and when a battery gets involved so
there's there's different risk and that
may imply there's a cost
difference thank you uh representative
Connor
please excuse me represent melin thank
you thank you for let me thank you for
taking my question uh have you talked to
the Automobile Association the toen
association about when these cars get in
an accident and they haven't caught fire
yet but you put it on the back of your
flatbed and it catches on fire have you
had any discussion about that yes sir
they they were part of the discussion we
brought together this summer and they've
been part of the three meetings that
we've had so far um some of them are are
recommending just putting them in a
different spot in their yards or put in
like Jersey barriers or something like
that block the block big concrete blocks
to help protect them and segregate them
for 30 to 90 days and that's still
something they're trying to figure out
the time frame for but yes they they
both have been included dealers Auto
automo deal automobile dealers sorry and
the
toe uh but have they has any one of them
turned around and said I won't tell that
um my understanding is yes but I can't I
can't give you an example um and
thoroughly we've heard that happen but I
can't tell you today in a specific
example of that okay thank you further
questions yes
please thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Pon I AP Peterson I
apologize are you aware of
um alternative batteries to lithium
batteries such as the solid state
batteries and sodium batteries do they
have the same intense fire hazards that
the lithium batteries have we're being
told no um and we're being told there's
some stuff coming out on the lithium ion
batteries to change the science of those
to make them less of a uh risk for
thermal runaway but they're not
available is my understanding that part
of it yet but it's coming thank you
thank you further
questions uh yes Mr CH uh yes uh thank
you uh do you have any records or is
your office now or encouraging
municipalities to keep records on carire
vehicle fires and whether they're
electric vehicles versus non-electrical
Vehicles any sort of Statistics that you
started collecting uh yes sir we uh this
summer we started asking the fire chiefs
Through the Fire Chiefs Association some
email blasts that we've had we stood up
a small little quick survey for battery
fires car and car fires uh we've only
gotten one response so far and that was
a the lithium am battery it wasn't a
vehical related one uh but yes we are
the in the the US fire Administration is
undertaking a a major change in the
collection of fire data across the
country right now and I I suspect that
um they're working on the framework of
that at the moment but uh at the our our
current incident reporting system at the
state isn't sufficient to dive into that
level um so that's why we stood up that
that uh separate survey tool follow up
Mr chair uh do you know of any other
states that are keeping in statistics
especially our neighbors or other states
where if you wanted to compare we or we
could compare uh so so far the probably
the best one that's looking at data is
New York um and they're looking more at
the e-mobility type devices um is my
understanding Maryland I believe started
doing a study I haven't checked with
others but is um it is it's been part of
a conversation to try to collect the
data I think the the hold outs we being
told is the new nearest system which is
part of the emergency Reporting System
that's coming out from us fire
Administration should hopefully be sted
up by the end of this year we're hoping
that it will capture data so I think
some people kind of holding back without
having to create whole separate Data
Systems um since there's a new one in
the in the Works near near pretty close
thank you sir any further
questions I have I have a question
number one I applaud you and every
fireman throughout our state throughout
the country wonderful
job my my question is um what's before
us 1510 is establish a commission
identify barriers to and solutions for
electric vehicle
sales it would appear to me as you being
a member or someone being appointed to
that
commission the the barrier to uh sales
is the battery that runs the vehicle we
we know that where where do you see do
you see other
barriers um that would be help ful in in
a commission I I thank you and I I think
the the focus for us at the fire
Marshall's office is the fire safety
concerns I know there's other a bunch of
others that you know as representative
MC Williams talked about some of the
climate stuff and some of the things
that I I'm not I haven't studied that
side of it I really focused on the fire
side um and I think that we want to
focus on you know looking at other
battery uh Technologies um and trying to
help you know like the tow Association
how do you you know those those sorts of
things to understand you know if if it's
towed how do you protect it if it's in a
garage how do you protect it if it's on
the side of one of our Interstate
systems or you know something like that
like how does a fire department respond
to it so we want I think we want to
approach it from an educational
perspective okay um and just get that
messaging out thank you thank you um
thank you for your time sir thank you um
I would like to bring forward Jessica
Wilcox to testify once again before our
committee welcome to Public Works and
highways thank you very much chair and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Jessica Wilcox I'm the mobile
sources supervisor over at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and our team is is overseeing
the Volkswagen settlement funding um
which we're spending uh a big portion on
the buildout of electric vehicle
charging infrastructure in the state and
we were also um a participant in the
round table that the fire chief has
referred to we take no position on this
bill but we wanted to bring to your
attention that there were several EV or
electric vehicle related bills being
proposed in the house this session two
of them were in transportation and two
of them in the executive departments in
administration so far one of those bills
has been referred to interim study two
of those bills were voted inexpedient to
legislate and for the bill that has not
yet been voted on which addresses Pro
prohibiting electric vehicles and
parking garages we did testify and
recommend that the committee consider
referring it to interim study as
well um there's a lot that needs to be
researched as uh the Fire Marshall
mentioned having factual data and real
world data to clarify you know what are
the concerns what are the barriers um
definitions operations procedures these
are all things that need to be discussed
and and dealt with um through more time
and more um and more attention now there
are actually two bills that would would
create study committees which the
sponsor did reference this bill and then
Senate Bill 430 um which the Senate
Transportation committee voted ought to
pass and both of these bills would could
be potential we see them as potential
vehicles for addressing a lot of these
concerns and issues that are being
raised so uh we like the idea that if
those bills could be matched together
through that reconciliation process that
seems to be a good a good path forward
both of those bills also list several of
the same members including the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and as we have been
participating in discussions up till now
we are happy and pleased to continue
those discussions and to serve as a
resource to you all because we have been
uh working on this for for a long time
and recent DMV data is showing that so
far in New Hampshire we're seeing 10,000
electric vehicles on the road so we're
seeing that growth these are coming so
lot a lot of work to be done that's all
I have thank you so much for your time
thank you are there questions from ad
will Cox represent CL uh yes you said
there are now 10,000 electric vehicles
on the road in our state registered
registered okay do you have like and
what what was it let's say two or three
years ago do you have any data on that
if memory serves I think a few years
back we were at about 6,000 we're seeing
like a 15% growth on average
year-over-year okay so you expect follow
up CL a 15% growth let's say next year
and the year after is that what you're
saying so that was kind of how we were
looking at initially when we looked at
that data but um ISO New England who
operates the regional electric grid in
the area has actually done some
forecasts and per their forecast they
are projecting that by
2031 we should see 140,000 electric
vehicles on the road and that is broken
down by year I think by 2025 they pro
project 30,000 electric vehicles on the
road in New Hampshire all okay thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you further
questions
yes please thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question it in that
10,000 number does that include hybrids
and plug-in hybrids that's correct
that's not all battery electric that
includes the plug-in Hy electric
vehicles not the standard hybrids that
don't plug into charge thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony um that is that concludes that
concludes what I have for pin cards was
there anything else the sponsor wanted
to mention or anyone that has spoken
previous or would you like to come
forward one more
time thank you very much for the
opportunity um I understand you're going
to be executing this bill today we may
okay you may be executing this bill
today um in the to the extent that there
may need to be an amendment I would be
happy to do an amendment if you need to
bump the exec I'm flexible I I think
that this is worth studying um also I do
want to mention I know my colleague from
Dees didn't mention that there was one
more EV V bill at st& which uh was exec
yesterday it was a tie 1010 so I don't
expect we're going to see much more
traction on that bill but um that was a
cash on the hoods uh it's not 10,000 or
20 sorry $1,000 or $2,000 cash on the
hoods um using Reggie funds for a
two-year pilot we'll see if that goes
anywhere but that bill uh was exact
yesterday at St um so I'm happy to
answer other questions that may have
come up since the last time I spoke it's
a pleasure to be in front of you would
you take a question from the chair of
course thank
you commissions are are are a hard thing
to pull together right now in the
climate especially a three-year
commission and the cost of
Representatives seem to like to be paid
when they show up to come to a
commission would do do you foresee you'd
mentioned and if I'm out of line you
please tell me you mentioned that one of
your concerns is a federal issue uh that
is tied to the State issue because we
won't come to that uh particulate amount
that triggers getting more units in here
would you consider somehow making this a
committee do you foresee that as opposed
to being a commission a working group or
some other
form or are you looking to have the
weight of the commission I'm just asking
you to think about that as you as you go
forward
um thank you for the question chair I
hadn't really considered that until this
moment um so I'm digesting it I think
that if it were a committee it would
still need some time to actually come to
to a data driven conclusion and I think
the committee would want to be able to
call upon the members of the commission
that were list Ed in the amendment in
order to get testimony and data um so
whether the members of the commission as
written right now were truly
participants or simply attendees who
could speak up I think we would probably
come to the same conclusions eventually
so thinking this through I do not
believe that the makeup between
committee or commission is really that
important and I'm certainly not wedded
to it I think the goal is to come up
with answers and data so that we can
move forward as a state one more
question and I apologize for not knowing
your background what committee do you
are you a member of I'm on science
technology and energy I'm an architect
and attorney and of course the State Rep
so you're busy I'm busy thank you you're
welome any further questions yes
please Peterson thank you Mr chair I
have one more technical question for you
concerning the EVS uh with the extreme
heavy weight of the batteries has there
been much talk about the
uh wear and tear on the tires and wear
and tear on the roads especially in hot
climates where the tires wear out
quickly and the roads get torn up
because uh the asphalt is soft and the
cars are extremely
heavy um I'm not privy to that specific
discussion in terms of hot climate
asphalt and tires um but I will tell you
that everything old is new again and
certainly we were having the same
conversations Generations back when we
were converting from horse and buggy to
internal combustion engine in terms of
deciding to pave our roads and do
highways across the country and so we're
we're probably there again in terms of
changes with Tire makeup and potentially
Road surfaces as well we'll see time
will tell but everything old is new
again thank you you're welcome um and if
I could just mention chair I would be
willing to serve on a committee or a
commission this is really important to
me okay thank you thank I I thank you I
appreciate yours and and all that have
attended thank you we will uh if there's
no other no one else wishing to testify
at this point in time we will call to a
close uh House Bill
1510 and with the included Amendment
thank
you do we have a blue
sheet
point of order Mr chairman yes would it
be possible to have a very brief recess
before reconvening and I'm presuming
that you're going to suggest that we go
into caucus yes okay that's thank
you our committee will be in recess for
the next 20 minutes at which time we
will come back together and we have a
list of bills whether we get through
that or not but that's where we're going
to go I would ask the
Republicans uh to move to our empty
Ballroom which used to be our office
okay so it's all right we caucus it
certainly
is
let's open up executive session today
being
Wednesday uh
2724 uh Public Works and
highways um we have uh the
possibility nine bills to exec I'm going
to come out and say that two of those
will not be exec today one of them we've
got to get to quickly because it's an
early Bill 1202 FN I do not intend to
bring that one forward and I do not
intend to bring 1510 forward
today so we will we will start with uh
house Bill 1196 FN relative to request
for easements with a purpose of laying
sidewalk along class 1 to5 highways I
recognize representative Boyd for a
motion Mr chairman thank you very much
as it relates to House Bill 1196 with
fiscal note I move inexpedient to
legislate motion motion's been made and
seconded on House Bill 1196 6
FN um is there discussion on the
item seeing none the clerk uh will call
the rooll on 1196 FN if you're in favor
of that motion uh which is itl you'll
vote by saying I or yes if you're
opposed nay or no with that would the
chair with the clerk call the rooll
thank you thank you Mr chair
representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative faly
yes representative Newton
yes representative kazinski yes
representative Bowen yes representative
Boyd Boyd votes I representative Melvin
yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor yes representative
Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes e is not representative Peterson yes
representative vone
yes representative jurus
yes chairman mcon chairman votes I Mr
chair the vote passes
thank you consent consent um anyone have
uh we will place it on
consent just a point of order Mr chair I
did not was not paying attention I was
reading did we recognize representative
Eaton as being absent yes okay thank you
very
much we will pass on House Bill 1202 FN
we will move to uh House Bill 123 34
FN um and which is relative to the
repair of class six roads not maintained
by municipality and I will recognize
representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman I move inexpedient to legislate
seconded motion's been made and seconded
to uh itl House Bill 1234 FN is there
any discussion on the motion I can speak
briefly yes please I would like to thank
you uh we passed RSA 20 31 81a in
2019 uh to handle private roads the
problem being you couldn't get certain
types of federally guaranteed mortgages
on private roads and uh it was a it was
a compromise bill it took about three
years to pass every word of it is
carefully crafted to satisfy all the
stakeholders um this bill would have
extended those same protections to class
six roads which are unmaintained public
roads uh and but we learn that there is
no problem getting mortgages on class 6
roads so the original uh problem doesn't
come up and uh we only had testimony in
favor of it from one citizen uh some
stakeholders were opposed because uh
without the mortgage incentive uh they
were unhappy with the tension between
what does what does what what does
equitably mean in terms of funding the
maintenance depending on how you are
using the property and where your
Frontage is and whether you're using it
seasonally or year round so uh and it
was pointed out that one possibility
would be to convince the town to
discontinue the road then it would be a
private road and and this wouldn't come
up so um I would also point out I have
an amendment to this the problem the
there's a severe drafting error in the
in the as introduced version of the bill
so if we should get to a split split
vote uh where we where there's an OTP
possibility we have to make sure that
this bill does not come out with a bare
OTP so if if we should get a split vote
uh we will need a a Minority Report with
that as a as an amendment thank you
representative Jack yes that amendment's
already been drafted correct okay we
don't need it so right if if we get to
the floor you have something that to
offer I
guess could be yep thank you any further
questions um who was the second cluder
Boyd do you have anything you'd like to
add at this point
I I respectfully refer the committee to
the answers offered by representative
Jack some moments ago thank you thank
you any further
discussion seeing
none
um we will um if you're in favor of the
motion itl on 1234 FN uh you will
signify by saying I or yes if you were
oppos nay or no um with that would the
clerk please call the rooll thank you Mr
chair representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fidi yes representative
Newton yes representative kazinski yes
representative B
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin I representative
bogert yes representative
Connor representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative eat is not here
representative Peterson yes yes
representative vone
yes representative jurus
yes chairman mcon chairman votes I Mr
chair the motion itl passes
190 and without objection we will place
it on
consent seeing
none we'll move to exac on House Bill
1262 f F relative the installation of a
traffic signal at the intersection of
Route 111 and Elmer Road in
Salem um Mr chairman I would recognize
the vice chairman represent cluder I
move itl on House Bill
1262 motion's been made SEC seconded by
Mills um
discussion u i will F I'll first go to
um to represent clud I tried to listen
take notes during the testimony and just
that do is recommending a
roundabout uh and I mean the the
signalized according to the testimony
isn't in the 10-year plan so it I I I if
they want to signalize I don't know
maybe you ought to come and ask for
Amendment to the 10year plan but I don't
think this bill is the way to go because
we try as much as we can to to respect
the process of the 10-year plan and so
that's why urge itl on House Bill 1262
represent Mills do you have a
comment yeah if I could just oh yeah
represent back yeah we also learned that
the this particular intersection does
not satisfy the signal warrants for a
traffic signal so one cannot be built at
that
intersection thank you further and
representative Mills agrees with the
previous two Representatives thank
you R boy thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman I'm going to be opposing itl
for the simple fact that it's the it's
desirous of the town of s to have a
signalized um structure at that
particular intersection it was not clear
to me that an analysis had been done
whether to justify a signal at that
intersection or not I would have
preferred to have seen interim studying
if anything to you know as uh to amplify
ruia's comments so that a further cons
discussion may be had as to what would
be the appropriate project to be placing
into the 10-year plan so with that being
said uh I will be voting in the negative
thank
you represent
p i uh I'm in favor of itl and I think
that the reason is that we rely on the
10-year plan process the project in the
10-year plan doesn't specify exactly
what the design is it's a project that's
funded it's gone through the
process you know we can't get involved
with the uh
integr design decisions of every project
in the state nor should we in my opinion
so I'm in favor of
it thank you please representative well
well I I agreed that we should it on
this bill because you look where they
are in the process and the timing of
this it I think um given the history of
the the recent uh automobile accidents
that have taken place I think this isn't
going to speed up the process of
resolving preventing another death I
mean I think the 10-year plan contains
is moving along and probably will
resolve come up with a resolution in
just about the same time so I don't
think it's necessary to try to rush this
project I nor do I think it will thank
you representative any further
comment thank
you motion's been made and has been
seconded on House Bill 1262 FN relative
the insulation of traffic signal at the
intersection of Route 111 in Elmer rhod
and Salem if you're in favor of that
motion you'll signify by saying I or yes
and oppose nay or no uh with that uh M
clerk would you call the role thank you
Mr chair representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
yes representative Newton yes
representative
kazinski representative Bowden yes
representative Boyd Boyd votes he
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative fauler yes representative
Newman
yes representative Eaton is no vote
representative Peterson yes
representative vone yes representative
jurus yes chairman mccon chairman votes
I Mr chair the motion of itl passes
181 without objection consent
calendar no objection Mr chairman thank
you we will be on
consent we will now move
to House Bill 1439 relative to vehicle
registrations and reciprocal toll
collection enforcement agreements and I
recognized representative boy Mr
chairman thank you very much for House
Bill 1439 fiscal note I move inexpedient
to
legislate motion inexpedient to
legislate and seconded
by second second by U represent Mills uh
discussion here I just with all due
respect and I know the the sponsor put
this in was consent about our
constituents the thing is this is going
to cost the turnpike fund money and it's
not fair to users of the turnpike fund
so I strongly support itl thank you
thank you for your comments any further
discussion motion's been made itl on
House Bill 1439 FN if you're in favor of
that motion you'll signify by saying I
or yes and if you were oppos nay or no
with that would the clerk please call
the rooll thank you Mr chair
representative cluder yes representative
Mills votes yes representative
Falin representative Newton yes
representative
kazinski representative
Bowen representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin I representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative Eaton is no vote
representative Peterson yes
representative vone yes representative
jurus yes chairman mononi chairman vot
Mr chair the motion itl passes
190 thank you without objection
consent thank
you we'll
see the
um so we will move now to House Bill
1464 uh we just did that no no we didn't
no no where you're right 1464 come to J
yeah all right so sorry for for that
establishing establishing a committee to
study Revenue alternatives to the road
toll road toll registration charges
relative alternatives to vehicle
registration fees including electric
registration fees the chair um calls
representive Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman I move inexpedient to
legislate I will second that motion and
does representative Jack want to speak
to his motion I will need to do that uh
this is a fine Bill uh it establishes a
committee a study committee which would
have to end in November I have an
amendment to a bill that we will
consider in a few minutes that
establishes a commission that makes the
commission charge the same as the charge
in this bill so that the commission can
study both the road toll and the
registration fee and that makes this
redundant and not as good because it's
not as long lasting and it doesn't have
as many
stakeholders
thank you the second want to make a any
further
comment is there any discussion on House
Bill
1464 per Sam Connor you did you want to
say something okay uh seeing none if
you're in favor of the motion itl on
House Bill 1464 establishing a committee
to study Revenue alternatives to the
road toll road toll registration charges
Revenue alternatives to vehicle
registration fees including electric
vehicle registration fees you would
signify by saying I or yes and if you
were opposed to that motion you would
say nay or no with that would you call
the role thank you Mr chair
representative cier yes representative
bills votes yes representative fedolfi
yes representative Newton yes
representative kazinski yes
representative Bowen yes representative
Boyd boy votes I representative Melvin
yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor yes representative
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar I representative
Faulkner yes representative Newman
yes representative Eaton is no vote
representative Peterson yes
representative vone yes
representative jurus yes chairman mcon
thank you chairman votes I Mr chair the
motion itl passes 19 Z thank you Mr
clerk we will move uh consent yeah
without objection
consent contact the
sponsor I'll contact this to
explain
okay did you say say you're going to
contact him or you want me to okay thank
thank you so much for
that we will now go to House Bill 1468
FNA directing the Department of
Transportation develop a Conway Branch
rail line master plan this is as amended
FNA I would um like to make the motion
ought to pass
second yes the amendment um we're going
with the amendment that was offered by
um representative
Smith which
was okay I'm sorry
okay yeah thank you who's got the I I
turned mine in already yeah I have a
copy of it one second
please just the numbers yeah I'll move
2024 hyphen 0530
H 0 five
30 as in
Hotel I move that Amendment
okay motion made by
um I'm Sorry by representative Mills
second by cluder um to the amendment for
mentioned Amendment um is there a
discussion on the
amendment this would be the amendment
that Smith had brought
forward what's Voice vote Voice vote if
you're in favor of that signifi by
saying I and raise your
hand is there any opposition seeing
none so now we will go back
to the um motion House Bill 1468 FN as
amended I made the motion I will make
the motion to ought to pass and it was
was second second
by second by
Mills it was okay
discussion seeing none if you're if
you're in favor of um ought to pass on
House Bill
1468 FN is amended you signified by
saying I if you oppose nay or no uh with
that would the clerk call the role
please thank you Mr chair representative
cluder yes representative Mills votes
yes representative fidal yes
representative Newton yes representative
kazinski yes representative Bowen yes
representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar I representative
fogner yes representative Newman
yes representative Eden is a no vote
representative Peterson yes
representative vone yes representative
jurus yes chairman makoni the chairman
votes I Mr chair the motion ought to
pass as amended is passes
without objection
consent is this a bill because it has an
appropriation is it allowed to go on
consent I think um we we don't have to
put it on consent I believe the fysical
note's going to come off of the uh of
the bill but it it does say FN it so
leave it leave it off we will put it on
the regular calendar thank
you 31 um so we will pass on House Bill
1510 is a courtesy to the to the sponsor
to the bill that we just heard we will
move on to House Bill
1631 thank
you represent Jack is Distributing an
amendment we'll give him some time to
look at that this bill is relative to
extending the commission to study
Revenue alternatives to the road
toll we will give this a moment
thank
you thank you
Mar
the chair recognizes representative Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass and I will offer
Amendment
0525 H thank you 0 second I second
second it by cluder would you care to
speak to your Amendment represent Jack
as I mentioned a few minutes ago on the
other Bill the amendment modifies the
charge of the commission to be equal to
the charge of the study committee that
we just ited so that the commission can
study both the rotol and the
registration fee that's the only effect
of the
amendment is there a
discussion yes please represent yeah I I
just got a question um on this
um line 24 to 26 says all Motor
Vehicles contribute proportionately
including Vehicles registered out of
state that may no longer be subject to
the road toll what what does that refer
to
anyway Jack well I would refer that
question to the prime
sponsor which
we the excuse me representative Jack are
you referring to the previous uh or to
the commission
commission that that would be
me it's a fine question
representative I think I remember the
answer that we to discuss beforehand
that thank you please if we
don't have the uh road to gas
tax and collect through registration
fees then there's a missing element
people from other states who drive on
our roads aren't paying so they want to
look at ways that that we might recover
from
that that loss if we don't have
the kazinski does that satisfy
your would that be like say electric
vehicles or something is that what
that's referring to be know some other
states driving through the
state or in the state wouldn't be paying
registration fees
so uh is there a way to have them pay a
fair
share uh it could be any type of
vehicle um again they're looking at
alternatives to the gas tax so maybe
replacing it or replacing it in part or
recognizing the fact that we're not
collecting as much from from the gas tax
because
of increased
U vehicle you know efficiency so if if
the road toll the commission has already
been looking at other states that are
doing a charge by the mile and they um
because the problem problem always comes
up with where so many people are coming
through here um we're losing Revenue but
how do we capture if we're not if we
don't have the registration fee how
we're going to capture that and that's
part of the whole issue with the
commission is there a model out there
that'll make up that difference and one
of those models is a miles
traveled uh there's some technology
heading that way some of the states are
doing self-reporting some of the states
are um are collecting that from uh every
time you register your vehicle but then
how does our state get that portion it's
a huge dilemma and that's what we're
looking at okay I don't think clouds it
represent Jack do you see I don't see
this clouding the other Commission
okay further questions yes yeah and this
this the bill where this will only make
it go till the end of this year no this
commission extends out to 2026 okay did
that have to say that in this amendment
anywhere because it doesn't I I believe
it's Incorporated this would incorporate
into the bill for the commission and the
commission speaks of going to
2026 and then once if if we get um if I
give you some background so so this this
again is going to take the governor
months before it makes it to the bill if
we make it through the process again it
usually has steam to do that we have
talked about forming a subcommittee in
public works once we know people are
interested in this moving forward that
we would then invite
do um Environmental Services all the
players to come in and we'll work on it
during that inum period so by the time
we pick this back up in September that
you know we haven't lost the
steam so that's that's the
intent okay so um motion is to accept
the amendment uh as stated if you are is
there any further discussion before we
call a hand vote yes please I'm I'm just
going to uh throw this out here in South
NASA there are gas stations gas pumps
at BJ's and at Sam's and there are a lot
of outof State people that come up and I
just want to comment that I can remember
sometime in the last few
years
do I'm pretty sure I heard it from
through do they keep track of because
you enter if if you're charging it
you're putting in your zip code and they
can keep track of out of state things
would would Vehicles typically coming up
from Massachusetts buying gas up here
but then racing back to Massachusetts
would they get caught up in this also or
the commission could look at that so
commiss to look the commissions to look
at that as far as the gas concerned if
they if they come into our state and buy
gas we're getting we're getting the
revenue from that getting the revenue
there there's a whole there's a whole
issue with how for us to get paid for
people that charge in our state and that
that has just not been worked out yet
because our state is is a different
system of electric utilities and some
states they've worked it out and we're
hoping that part of the charge of the
commission is to find a way for us to
capture some of that money and then you
know so that's that's where we're at
it's complicated there are a lot of
great Partners we've kept the same
people together uh will involve the
committee once this passes through the
house and the senate or at least through
the house will start meeting and then I
would invite committee members then to
join us as non- voting members but um it
we have we have made sure in this bill
that Public Works has major seats at
this and uh to to date um I have been
chosen as uh the chairman of that that
could always be subject to
change um okay so we haven't voted on
the amendment yet have we okay so I'm
sorry I got we haven't no we haven't
voted on the amendment okay so if you're
in favor of the amendment and the do we
have the amendment number one more
time 0 0525 H okay thank you
representative Jack motion's been made
in second if you're in favor of that
Amendment raise your hand signify by
saying I thank you any opposed motion
carries we will now move on to House
Bill 1631
relatively extending the commission to
study Revenue alternatives to the road
toll we have a motion I will make the
motion not to pass I'll second as am as
amended as
amended is there
discussion I just miss I'm strong
support we need to continue our work as
commission I've been working at the
pleasure of working with you and other
members of the commission I think we
need to keep it up and hopefully we can
get some work done in the next few
months thank
you any further comment yes represent
just just the same basically the same
comment this this commission is actually
probably been going on for 10 years 12
years but
unfortunately every two years there's
new players there's new people elected
and it had to start all over again and
this time we recognized we had some
return members so this is our attempt to
get this to become a permanent
commission that reports to this Public
Works committee and it just can go on as
long as it takes to get to a solution to
this thank you further
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion um ought to pass house Bill 1631
is amended you'll signify by saying I or
yes if you're opposed to the motion you
will signify by saying no or nay with
that would the clerk please call the
role thank you Mr chair representative
cluder yes representative Mills votes
yes representative fidy yes
representative Newton yes representative
kazinski representative Bowen yes
representative Boyd Boyd Bai
representative Melvin hi representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar hi
repres representative fauler yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton is no vote representative Peterson
yes representative vone yes
representative jurus yes chairman mccon
v i Mr chair the motion ought to pass as
amended passes
190 thank you I want to thank the um as
always um consent we
go uh there is I without objection
consent do you have a you want a comment
please represent abot uh yes I just
wondered I I know um representative
fidal asked you and I but I don't
remember your response when we're going
to get the printed copy of the tenure
plan I and thank you I received a copy
of it in my mailbox down uh downstairs
and I thank you for saying that I didn't
know if anyone else apparently no one
else has received it no
I okay Kathy do I need to speak to the
governor's office for that or
do you're you you're the bestest thank
you for that um looking ahead to next
week so we have we have a hard deadline
on at least one of our
bills um is an early
bill um I was going to next Wednesday
Valentine's Day no better day to open up
the 10-year plan um we're going to open
up I believe I have to change some
normic clature in the in the 10year plan
Kathy if you can help me on that when
we're done I will do that
I would like to spend the day with I
believe the term will be work
sessions um with different department
heads of do providing a background of of
their expertise my thought is we're
going to be here
Thursday for a session in the afternoon
the governor is going to do is it the
State of the State the governor will do
the State of the State and then we're
going to have session afterwards so we
have to be here anyway so my thought is
we'll we'll take a long day on Wednesday
Wednesday and we will go at what we say
10 10 to 12 uh with with more uh
presentations from do and I'll work out
those details so that you have some
planning and it should go into
Thursday's um Thursday's calendar and my
intent is that we will meet at least two
days a week each week going forward uh
once I see what that breath and Kathy
has provided me or or Christy has
provided me with what we've done in the
past so that we can work our way through
this uh with a few long days and get
through the 10-year
plan is there objection I know some of
you have work commitments so we'll we'll
try and Hammer that out
tomorrow I I believe I yeah I believe
we've traditionally Kath you want to
speak to that but I believe we
traditionally hear from the
Departments and then so here the
presentations
and
okay yeah the 14th is noticed for as a
public
hear and I believe it's been brought to
my attention it shouldn't be listed as a
public hearing it should be what was the
verbiage
there agency presentations
and I don't know if
holding same
day I I believe in the past and someone
please correct me John someone else
that's been here I I
believe we haven't done the public input
until we've been through the
presentations Ty yeah I think vaguely Mr
chair that we haven't done usually we've
done a presentation then we may do a
public hearing on the um on another day
from but it can vary from year chair to
chair but this is what we we've done it
I think last term we did presentations
and then a public hearing as I vaguely
remember for a public notice it would
appear that your records have been water
damaged and no longer to be found okay
so we're going to exclude yours okay um
Chrissy you would you would spend some
time on that do you want to comment on
it now or you would talk afterwards
yeah 20 because 2020 was Co we didn't
have a
for I don't believe we did
I well I I I think we've done that
before I I remember Vegas once we had
the uh the presentation because it was
one of those years where there there
wasn't any
argumentative positions to be had so the
and we held the public hearing
afterwards like we took the presentation
didn't take all day yeah we had rather
than do it over two days we had the
presentation in the morning let's just
say and then the public Hearing in the
afternoon and if we had nobody at the
public hearing we just closed it went on
our way the other ways that we've done
it is just have a day for the
presentation then the next time we'd
have the public
hearing and all was in the schedule it
was if the public hearing was only going
to be an hour or so we would go right
into the work session from there work
sessions after the public hearings after
the public hearings okay so if if you
have interest in this why don't you stay
uh because we're going to figure this
out while I have Kathy do you have some
time to stay Thank you and we have
Christy here Christy do you have a some
time to spend thank you so we'll we'll
Hammer this out and anyone that wants to
stay is welcome to stay uh those that
want to leave I will recess the meeting
and just knowing that um we're going to
be here next
week believe yeah so anybody anybody
that has a blurb I would appreciate them
today the latest is tomorrow morning at
10:
a.m. me see who do I am okay
so if you if you don't want to be a part
of the discussion on the on the public
hearings then you're free to go and I
want to thank one and all again for our
work as I say to everyone else I'm so
proud that we work
together